welcome everybody to the penultimate
match of the opening round of the
speed chess championship i'm grand master
robert hess alongside me my good friend
grandmaster marie sashi maurice are you ready
for this jan christoph duda versus fabi showdown
robert you know i was born ready what's up
what's up we're gonna do this it's gonna be fun
fabi versus duda this one should be interesting
i'm hearing some hate for fobby but we'll see how
the big dog gets it done you know he's
number two in the world for a reason
he certainly is number two in the world classical
chess this is a blitz format which hasn't always
been his specialty and as we remind everybody what
the format is today same as usual it is a single
elimination knockout bracket there will be 90
minutes an hour and a half of five minute plus one
second increment time control chest followed by an
hour of three plus one and then finally we get our
30 minutes of bullet one minute plus one second
increment the action will really heat up and if a
match is tied we will get four additional bullet
matches that should favor young christophe duda
we'll talk about that in a moment but before we do
maurice the prize fund thirty-two thousand dollars
are dished out in the opening yeah exactly cash
money right two thousand bucks to the winner
plus two thousand split by win percentage and what
do you think about that because it does motivate
people to play every single game you know we did
the same thing with clutch chess to add a little
spice to it it is important i think the players
sometimes when they get their heads bashed in
it's hard to keep playing you don't want
to play any more games please please could
i resign could i be out of here but hey if
there's a little bit of extra cash on the line
let's keep playing why not motivate them a little
bit more and if uh they need any more motivation
wesley so awaits the winner of this match in the
quarterfinals of the speedchest championship and
marie says you look across the bracket i can't
really imagine there are surprises this early
but what do you make of the participants in the
uh quarterfinals and who do you think is going to
win tomorrow's matchup before we get to today's
between anish giri and vladislav artemyev
well these are big names in chess there's no
surprises here they're people who are just
animals sharks i mean you look at levon
aronian what he did to nepo i mean these
are just fantastic players these are the world's
elite so i think this one is awesome when we get
the chance to get down to the next level in
the next level and the next level i gotta say
artemiev is really impressive man he's scary he's
scary of course anybody could win the match but
i'd say watch out for him okay i think
that's a fair call magnus carlson
really hinted as much saying that he wants to
play the stronger player was trolling a niche but
it's true artemia is an absolute beast and
well those players will be playing tomorrow but
everybody who's watching can get involved today
because there is money at stake for our viewers
if you guess the move on chess.com you have a
chance at some prize money there are grandmasters
and other title players taking part in it but
that doesn't mean that they're going to win and
the game that is chosen is not yet selected so you
just have to participate as much as possible and
get a chance to win some cash money and you know
bragging rights some glory just guess the move
exactly i wanted you to say that i didn't
want to say it so i'm glad you took the
lead there and maurice now it's time for
jan christoph duda versus fabiano caruana
you see that their blitz ratings are such that
duda a bit higher rated his performance in speed
chess championships past is clearly better and he
is predicted to win according to our smarter chess
predictions brought to us by chess goals i have
a problem with this graphic but i always have
problems with smart chess predictions
so maurice what do you think about this
i mean 77 now the number two player in
the world is going to get mauled i mean
that just seems a bit outrageous i get it it looks
as though he's skewing high in the bullet portion
where you really have to be somebody who
plays a lot of bullet over and over and
over again to really get it but geez to just
see bobby getting this kind of disrespect
i mean uh maybe 60 40 but 77 23 that's just a
blowout no love at all i i think it's preposterous
i'm pretty upset about it but i understand it at
the same time fabi has not proven historically
to be the best online speeches player that said
during this unfortunate pandemic he clearly has
improved his game all the various events that he
has taken part in has shown that he is a promising
blitz player these days and i think that it will
be much closer than that prediction indicates
seven to three in bullet what is a one second
increment not buying it not today but maurice
i'll add as well there's no category that he's
been giving any edge zero okay like no love for
him in any category that's i fabi c has known this
number beforehand if he knows it he's got to be
really ticked off and ready to take this
personally try to take dude down and prove
the world wrong well we're going to have him
try to prove that in just a moment because
the game should start any second now and
yeah maurice i can't get over that i mean
no advantages whatsoever but let's see if
he can create an advantage over the board
we do have lived off and oh the french don't
do this to me maurice oh i can't handle it
hating on the french but bobby's no doubt going to
try to surprise his opponent with some different
ideas both of them looking sharp fresh by the
way you see that they're all cleaned up fabi's
hair is significantly shorter than in the promo
pic so we'll see if that's because he's ready
to play some fresh moves on the board this french
i'm not a fan i don't like having my bishop stuck
on c8 and crammed and trying to break out
of a structure when white has all the space
yeah but fabi has been known to play it
before and it's a very complex position
yeah it's funny because i've seen fabi crush
opponents on the white side of french's in
u.s championships past in particular and this
bishop on c8 it's typically a horrendous piece
but why is duda spending some time here like why
did he take so long before playing bishop e2 this
is still mainline theory i guess he was choosing
do i want to castle queenside or kingside well he
knows fabi did not just drop this on the board
out of the sky i mean fabian has prepared this
specifically for this match he's thought about it
carefully he's one of the best prepared players on
the planet if anything you'll say fabi's main
strength is his preparation is opening ideas
that he's going to come with to beat you down so
clearly duda wants to get into something a little
bit different maybe not the most popular position
and maybe not the sharpest lines that fabi has
analyzed in depth to the finish yeah and there are
possibilities to exchange a lot of pieces on the
d4 square which i'm highlighting here and perhaps
that's what fabi wants in game one is an end game
something that isn't too sharp because in a lot
of positions white can try to blast through f5 but
not happening when d4 and then e5 will collapse so
he is preventing the more aggressive plans and now
duda spending even more time are we sure that
dude is going to be the favorite in this match
based on the early clock usage as you said maurice
preparation favoring fabiano yes indeed and that's
a lot of time to be burning right now is it move
12 or something i mean this is this is crazy that
this much thought went into this early opposition
and finally he did capture on the c5 square
we'll see more trades occur without a doubt the
dark square bishops will be coming off the board
without any question and there we go and you
got to say fabi for the clock as far as this
position is concerned not only that i don't see
the domination by white here it seems as though
d4 will happen very soon for black can he do
it even now robert can can he drop in a d4 move
definitely right because if d4 and if you
take with the knight there's gonna be a
quick rook b8 but he plays bishop b7 first so yeah
that that that's a little surprising to me i would
have loved to put a pawn on d4 and also chase
the the knight that's on c3 to a weird circuit
yeah let's take a look at that we'll bring
up the analysis board here just to go back
and move here because d4 maurice ideas kick
this knight and if the knight captures on d4
here comes a rook d8 and that's a devastating
thing that's absolutely deadly and and where
would the knight on c3 go before this this is my
key point he'd have to play knight d1 and send it
over to f2 etc but what what do we hate on this
one our bishop on b7 with a rook on the d-line
and it's party all day i'm surprised that
he didn't go for this line he played bishop
b7 instead and bishop d3 came immediately and
now the question after d4 is can he just play
knight e4 and say hey thanks no problem
you let my knight get to a decent square
so a little bit problematic in
my mind by fabi and now he spent
some time before finally playing rook ada and
looking again to maybe playing d4 in the future
seems like he missed the opportunity just a second
before i'm with you maurice because uh now if he
puts his pawn on d4 he's probably worried about
the eventual end game has that pawn gone too far
and becoming a weakness rather than a potential
strength and queen f2 played pinning this knight
on c5 and covering the d4 square a little more i
also was threatening also threatening the blast
bishop 87 check and finish you off so good point
sticks to deal with that uh that's a very good
point that's why h6 was played because of that
typical sacrifice he makes them look like rook
d7 in comes the sacrifice queen h4 knight g5 queen
h7 all happening very quickly so instead we got h6
stopping all of that at once no knight g5s no
bishop sacrifices uh but i am surprised maurice
and we have been talking about it but the fact
that he didn't play d4 what do you think that
says about fabi more generally are we reading too
much into it if we start speculating let's just
say he missed it let's just say he missed that
chance for now and that's all let's they're both
warming up duda not playing with his normal
alacrity he's down at 211 right now fabi also
maybe not finding all the nuances instantly or
that opportunity when it knocks but it could
be a big deal guys a big deal because now
duda has all this space robert d4 doesn't
make any sense at all now zero sense forget it
fabi has got to look for play from somewhere
the threat is rook to e1 rook ae1 followed by
f5 and blast away where is black's counterplay
i'm not seeing it right that's the big problem is
once that knight got kicked back to d7 and then
white's queen swung into the action here it feels
like white has a very free hand and normally make
moves like f6 the typical move to play in the
french to chisel at white structure but that's
two weakening look at these light squares that
are going to be penetrated by white's pieces so
i mean i i'm just not seeing an easy move for
fabi and now the clock situation look at that you
made the point you made a great point the clock
situation is indicative of the fact that black
has gotten a worse version of the french than you
want to have you want some play you want to move
and now he has played f6 because what else is
there to do robert the black is stuck for a plan
black had no normal peace moves pawn breaks a5
who cares you're about to get killed on king side
he had to do something to compete with
the attack on this side of the board
yeah so he plays f6 and at the very least what
can capture on f6 bring that rook a to e1 that you
suggested and e6 becoming a quick target but oh
the evaluation bar did not like the capture on f6
and okay it's swinging back and forth a bit
uncertain about the longer term prospects of
this but i see that pawn e6 maurice i'm not liking
that well there's gonna have to be some kind of
tricky tactic somewhere i think that a an e5 move
by black's gonna have to come with some weirdness
the problem i have for black's position right now
is that knight on c6 and that bishop on b7 these
pieces have to breathe somehow how are they going
to get in the game can he play maybe knight e7 to
f5 robert and hope for rain in a line like that
i pray that you don't get killed maybe that's the
best thing to do because those pieces now are
just con highly congested on that side of the
board and unless you can find a break like e5 i
mean you can't play it you can't play you've got
to go for a this knight move somewhere either
d4 or e7 and pray you're not dying on the spot
yeah knight d4 is an interesting one trading
off some of the pieces and avoiding maybe a
more menacing attack but this what i'm having
trouble with maurice here is that even if you
fend off the attack there's still some positional
weaknesses in particulars upon e6 but i like your
idea your more general approach of saying i need
to open up the bishop my knight c6 isn't doing so
much so let me make a move like knight d4 to trade
off what could be a very aggressive piece piece
because knight g5 in many variations is a threat
going after e6 and saying haha you can't take me
because my bishop and queen will line up on the
h7 square so i do like your knight d4 move just to
get rid of some of the attackers but robert is it
a stone cold blunder because fabi's sitting here
30 40 maybe it's been a minute already
that he's sitting on this position
ticking down to 106. remember that gigantic
edge he had on the clock and finally he's
doubled rooks but you know you you got to double
rooks quickly and f5 on the board knight to e8
now backing up hoping against hope as his pieces
have become really weird even more weird we had
a nice possibility of being on d4 now it's on d8
and with the f5 break white's pieces are breathing
i i'm not feeling this position at all
but maybe he's still okay maybe his bishop
on b7 is holding things together on the square
d5 yeah that's important and i like how duda is
transferring his advantage because the
pawn e6 was backward and weak at target
but he's saying let me play f5 and take and
then give black an isolated pawn but at the same
time as you're highlighting it frees up black's
pieces this knight come in e6 you pre-move that
now this knight from c6 to e6 that's closer to the
king side it'll can go to f4 eventually don't drop
your knight on d7 if that knight moves out the
way and queen d6 it feels like fabi has completely
regrouped at the stage and the clock it's been
telling the story of the game race 33 seconds
of counting down for duda this is what fabi was
counting on these complex french's and remember
we said we wanted to see the move e5 happen well
it was ordered in order to remove that weakness
break open the game and give black some room but
f5 has done for black what e5 himself would have
done in a position like that and the game is open
black's pieces are much more coordinated right now
and this move knight to d1 robert that's not
saying anything bobby just needs to start pressing
forward and do it quickly knight f4 boss move
this is starting to look really good for black
i'm looking at your d4 move now open that bishop
attack tonight on e3 he's go he's probably going
for it because knight can't get to f5 so d4
simply kicks the knight back i guess it hangs
the pawn but there's so many tactics available
that rook out for first that's that's a great
start great start and this is all fabi now 12
seconds left for duda and he has no pieces to
to talk about when his queen moves d4 is
going to happen he's just like queen g3 d4
on the board he's got six seconds and he's got
to figure out what to do he's got to make a move
bishop takes f3 works because if rook takes
f3 then you could sacrifice your queen for
a back rank checkmate but he's going for the
same idea at knight e5 piling up the pressure
here is there rook g4 can that do the trick
yes sure rook g4 looks great right now is
and he can take with the queen and g2 is
hanging and now he's just sacrificing his
queen of admitting this position is busted now
favi just has to get the job done with 20 seconds
left two seconds for due to threats are going
to start hovering the knights are hoping that
somehow they can hold it together but nope quincy
won give me a piece bobby gets it done in the
first game with black from an inferior position he
does and we'll pull up the analysis board really
quickly because i want to show something that fabi
did which was excellent uh at this moment when the
rook captured on f8 on move 30 a lot of people
say i need to keep my knight protect it's all
under attack but you're losing that piece anyway
and much more important is keeping your king safe
and then so you could take on g2 so taking with
the king that reflex was really smart uh started
not taking the king too too the queen was really
smart by fabi because getting the king there
allows a check and maybe some defense queen takes
as you're losing g2 by force and that's that so
indeed that was certainly a fantastic performance
there by fabi and he he needed that win to start
to quiet the haters quality haters who say he's
going to get blasted if he keeps playing like this
all right let's be real though that was an uneven
game on both their parts duder needs to get into
this match like start to start to play with some
speed first of all don't get behind the way he did
on the clock initially i mean that was crazy like
right out of the opening remember he was how long
he spent on deciding to play bishop e2 as you
mentioned you cannot afford to do that in these
matches certainly not because he could have used
that time towards the end of the game and oh i
see what just happened here and the evaluation bar
is always telling it was at minus something minus
almost one and then it went down to slightly
better for white which means queen e6 probably
was the trick hitting both pawns at the same time
and actually there's no real way for white to
protect both because queen d3 runs into knight e5
so you protect e4 and c4 at once but i immediately
kick you out the way so queen e6 maurice that
looks like a missed opportunity did duda think
that maybe there was a trick a trap a preparation
by fabi waiting in the position we know fabi is
famous for dropping little nuances there but you
looks good to me we'll see whether or not they
go back in this line if fabi repeats it means
that he's confident that he did have a trick
if not then he would say wait a minute i think
i messed up my preparation there the guy could
have played queen e6 so we'll see these matches we
get to see a lot of games you're going to see the
theory repeated again and again they can't play
new positions every single time certainly not
and i do think that queen e6 is a move you almost
never play right so trying to say oh queen e6 here
makes sense you're much more likely to just play
your typical stuff because the queen on d8 is a
good square it defends e7 in the event excuse me
in the event of any kind of knight d5 and it also
can allow the queen to go over towards the queen
side and be useful there so it's a good square to
have the queen on more generally in these moroxy
bind structures but the bind is over marie's the
trade on b5 yes indeed and the point you make
is such a good point the knight on d5 also often
threatens to go to b6 forking anything that's
sitting if there's a rook on a when the queen's
on d7 everybody's getting forked by knight b6 but
the queen on d8 and now the rook on b8 there is no
knight b6 that's just history and nothing for
black to worry about and as you said the bind
is gone usually when the bind leaves especially
the king still on g1 and the pawn on h3 robert
who who's worried if you got the black pieces
certainly not me i'm with you i could tell by
the way you're saying it and black's mission looks
good and i'm here with you and actually that was
a great point by you about the b6 square
because knight d5 if that queen were on d7
there would be immediate problems but here you
could probably play the move e6 and say what
now the b6 square is covered no issues in black's
position trading off pieces that's why um probably
drop his knight back rook a8 and okay that pawn
a2 not exactly happy but how to make progress
here because it seems like white's going to play
rook c2 rook c1 and take over this open c file
so i kind of like white's position from a concrete
point of view but from a like the thought process
of my rook on it's powerful that is the only thing
i'm going for the bishop on g7 the rook on the
8th but that's not actually accomplishing all that
much right now i'm going to say that the move rook
8 actually is not an impressive move to me because
the knight on c6 is now tethered to the b4 pawn
and so by moving your rook away and letting
white consolidate with the move b3 and and
also guarding the c4 square white was going to do
that anyway right why was this going to do that
anyway so now you've created a situation where
your knight on c6 has to sit there pretty much
forever unless you defend that sucker again with
somebody else the rook was taking care of the job
of guarding that pawn you could have played rookie
any time you wanted to and he would have played b3
anyway so i'm a little bit i feel like it was a
slightly inaccurate move and maybe this knight
should have found e5 and play in that fashion even
here you might want to play something like a 95
at some point looking at the d3 square in the long
run but you can't move it like you just can't move
it so now white is just piled up on the c line
and black is checking out like what should he do
how do you how do you clarify the situation on the
board that's a an excellent point that rookie had
that one move threat the palm was under attack
but white's very obvious reply helped the case
for fabiano so here black does feel a bit stuck
so let's try to answer that question how do you
defend b4 in a meaningful way is white ready
to take on c5 because that is a hanging pawn
so if white wants to you can take on c5 give up
your bishop and say a pawn is a pawn and right 95
sorry robert knight d5 was a threat as well 95
going after the pawn on on beef uh four and also
the knight b6 idea with the rook on ba on ba was
guarding it the rook on a8 now your queen can't
leave so that that idea came back and he said wait
i can't move my queen i can't do anything i need
to play the move e6 to stop the knight from going
to d5 and now that has also weakened the d6 pawn
it certainly hasn't i probably would not
capture on c5 it's a way to steal upon the
initial position but that makes a2 loose and
it's an unopposed dark score bishop a move i
would consider though is knight d3 but instead he
focuses his energy on the d6 pawn right away is he
just going to scoop that off if you give him the
opportunity he certainly would like to and i guess
black should make him like bishop e5 to defend
while putting the bishop on a more aggressive
square robert the challenge here for black is to
find the concrete plan that maneuvers the pieces
in just the right way that's going to be the
challenge white i think should move the king off
of g1 and there's a the bishop move and this is
exposing the pieces you know that that bishop is a
problem the knight on c5 is a problem the pawn on
d6 is the only thing that's helping it this is a
just a second moment where blackwell looks like he
has to has to play knight takes d3 i'm not really
sure why he's taking so long do you see another
move it looks like looks like it's forced maybe
he was trying to make the follow-up as quickly
as possible so he was spending his time on the
second move rather than on knight 63 which i
agree that was the very obvious move and the
opportunity that i mentioned to get the knight
off of c6 finally when the b4 pawn is not hanging
this is a very critical moment for black
right now now that bishop on e5 looks like
it should be getting kicked with f4 i'm
not sure why why you would hesitate there
either it's not like your e4 pawn is going to
come under fire so f4 seems natural robert why
would bobby wait here i guess there's the decision
to be made about the stare down the c file because
i could take on c2 which relieves the pressure
on d6 and also removes a very important defender
in the long run of the pawn a2 but if you take
on c8 maybe this knight can even capture it to
get passive for the time being but again a2
is a problem that white needs to keep an eye
on himself so f4 definitely that's the idea i'm
looking to play as well but making it all work is
a little bit more difficult it seems all right
well the knight did take on ca the d6 pawn is
guarded forever now it is not going to be a target
you've got to hope your maybe your light square
pressure will be a factor i i got to tell you i'm
not i wasn't really a fan of this move rook takes
and again you see black now playing
the move queen a5 hitting the a pawn
guarding the b4 point no kind of pressure on this
pawn on d6 oh don't take on a2 fabi with a trick
don't touch that that you you would certainly
lose instantly to rook c8 as the rook would
be overworked and you know it's an idea here
maurices a4 because with this knight needing the
rook's defense a move like a4 could be possible
trying to take advantage of an overworked rook so
that's a big decision now for jkd is hey a4
would close the a file and then make b4 even look
worse so he needs to figure out a way to stop
that move from being played he could play king
g7 but bishop h6 chases him back and that's so he
cannot do that for that reason but now he's played
this move a4 take advantage of the pin pawn but
also this is a pawn sack well not quite this is a
very touch and go movie just played f4 followed
by queen takes d6 is playable but you hang b2
is i mean a2 i mean is that hmm no a4 may be
the way the positional way to handle it as you
said guard b5 the knight has no path into the
game and you keep all your threats i like it
and there it is and the point is after b takes
a three on poisson that drops the queen because
the rook no longer defends it so we will not be
seeing that on poisson move that's for sure and
that was still a move even with the knight back
on state we'll go back a quick second here let's
say played a move like h5 a4 as possible because
it takes on passant as rook takes c8 with check
the rook is overworked protecting the knight and
protecting the queen so that tactic was available
whether the knight went to a7 or remained on c8
but after a4 here jkd deep in the think tank plays
queen a6 but maurice it's very clear that white's
position has improved and importantly his pawn on
f3 still makes his center feel strong here so he
didn't even have to commit himself to anything
fabio not yet i think he will eventually
because black's bishop is just too strong
holding that square now the rook back to b8 a rook
that should never have left the b8 square in my
opinion and only 16 seconds left in this position
35 for fabi fabi just needs to find a couple of
improving moves at the moment keep the pressure on
his opponent is there a threat for black none that
we can spot maybe the d5 move is something he was
hoping for but he needs to make moves quickly now
as does fabi how does he improve get some pressure
f4 finally in the position and knight back to f3
here we go you can just take that if you want
it because you can't take with the queen and
the queen is stuck defending this 987 you've
given black and iceland f5 crashing through
this is it this is beasty play by fabi now
completely outplaying his opponent world class
chess as those pawns are split all the pawns in
black's position are split every which way there's
got to be multiple ways to win this position but
he's got to do it quickly he himself only has 12
seconds left and here comes queen 87 with bishop
c5 to follow in fact bishop c5 said bishop f2 was
probably stronger but here it comes bishop's got
pinning the knight rook f1 maybe here it comes oh
yeah everything is a threat right now and i think
probably just dropping your queen back yum yum
smacking on something and now he's found the
killer blow bishop d6 followed by rook f7 hello
that's it no no mas no mas fabiano caruana rolling
right now oh he is and that was a nice way to
finish that game we'll bring up the board one more
time very quickly to show how he broke through and
it's in some ways jkd asked for it by playing d5
himself towards the end there because by playing
d5 he got rid of his defenders on the f5 score but
that's happening regardless so take takes an f5
crashing through very quickly blacks pieces over
over on the queen side not helping this poor
king on g8 and the rest was very simple for fabi
crashing through here so pure class robert that
was pure class chess right there held attention
and then broke through when his opponent made
the critical error fantastic play so far by fabi
and it feels like he's warming up as well that's
the other thing it feels like he hasn't played
his best chess yet is that scary to say because
he seems like he's getting in a groove dude i
better find something quickly or else this match
i'm not going to say it could be over there is a
lot of bullet to play so a lot of games but man
bobby on a roll right now and look at this game
maurice he learned from his first game i guess
he played b4 first instead of putting the queen on
b6 and after b4 knight d1 a5 so he simply expanded
over here on the queen side and that's what white
you know white goes for the king side black goes
for the queen side it's kind of the point c4 am
i am i seeing this is this real you can play c4
that's uh okay that's not what they teach you in
the classical manuals robert you're supposed to
be going for f5 not attacking on the same side
as your opponent is to play such a move just
seems like it should not work out is there a d5
sighting right now is that some kind of madness
i don't think that could possibly work and if it
doesn't then black simply captures on d4 and then
puts his bishop on b7 and says thanks for freeing
my one bad piece that i've been crying about
what is this i don't know and he's spending
so much time here that i'm having a hard time
figuring it out because knight b6 heading to d5 as
well it's not just the diagonal you've given black
to d5 square there's a pawn there both blocking
the bishop and taking away from black's pieces so
i don't like this at all for young christophe
duda the engine the evaluation bar clearly
slightly favoring fabiano and the lead on the
scoreboard two nothing smarter chess where you at
where you at with that 78 or whatever it
was there's a long way to go robert let's
not speak too early still but i agree 2-zip to
start and two classy games as well not like all
the guy blundered and we see their quiet move
by by fabi maybe your knight v6 was a bit more
a little had a little bit more oomph to it but
bishop b7 you can't hate him for trying to get
his bishop on a sweet diagonal look at that bishop
just slicing down and this may be the time for
white to play d5 you're pointing out the bishop
is looking nice and strong there so playing d5
can close the diagonal and force black to capture
there because d5 e takes d5 bishop takes d5 maybe
my bishop can sit on e4 where it's challenging
yours on this nicely open long diagonal of
course black can just play knight b6 and into
c4 so not that great for white i totally agree
this this is a challenge but knight b6 as you
said knight b6 is coming on the next move and
no problem there and it looks like we have
seen the position robert you called it
now we do have a an imbalance and it is dynamic
in fact white has freed his pawns maybe your
knight v6 earlier like i said instead of the
bishop b7 move would have been far more pressing
more to the point but now white is thinking
dreaming one day please let me play f5 f6
let me keep queens on as well could i keep the
queens on fabi said no no no that's that's what
happens when you start threatening me we trade
queens off make sure that cannot happen but the
problem for black at the moment is that bishop
on b7 although it's solid although it's good
it's face is being faced off by this bishop on e4
so white got to sneak that in can black make some
moves get a knight maybe on c4 at some point how
does we chase away this bishop over the e4 square
that said robert you can't like white pieces
they look silly other than the bishop on e4
everybody else looks silly but there are prospects
right because it's pawn c5 we have to take into
account that there's an extra pawn for both sides
and different sides of the board right from the
e to the h file white has an extra pawn from
the a through c files black has an extra pawn
that typically favors the extra pawn on the queen
side in the end game because look at how far these
king on h1 is from black's extra pawn whereas
white's extra pawn e5 this king is super close
just to think about that as we may see some trades
in the future and as you were pointing out maurice
black's pieces are definitely better plays
the bishop on d2 doing a whole lot of nothing
the knight on e3 would love to jump into f5 but
the question is then what right you get to f5
great you attack my bishop i can move my bishop
away you're not really making the progress you so
desire and on the other side of things black's
pieces are ready to just jump into the action
robert i want to play knight f5 and then
when you move your bishop like queen g4
where's my queen i mean that's what you do when
you have the space on the king side to attack with
the reality is with this pawn formation you're
going to need and before i could even finish the
thought you're going to need to play f5 and e6
creating your own pass pawn he just played the
move g6 saying you want to try that go right
ahead there's no knight to f5 nothing there's
not there's no nothing over there if i'm gonna
use a double negative and piss off my english
teacher from grade school there is not there's no
na on that side of the board for white white has
to be thinking how do i settle down black because
black is looking at moves like c4 like you said
starting to get some some angles and might even
play a bishop d3 black has all kinds of options
in fact it's probably the problem for black is how
many moves does black have is there a knight a4
sighting in man that's a little bit too too much
maybe now i'm liking c4 eventually with with the
possibility of of more pressure in the position
and white just looking for things to do can't find
any moves i'm talking all this time robert the guy
is losing the same amount of time on the claw yes
you're absolutely right maurice and if you you're
kind of highlighting this but the squares black
has d5 under control which is what white's pieces
want to go to f5 we're looking at that square nope
not for you whereas d3 you can put that bishop
and double the rooks bring the next one over
it just feels like black dominates the control
of this board here and knight g4 are you really
trying to go knight f6 i can just take you
there right and thank you very much you moved
your night away thank you here's an attack on
both bishop and pawn on b2 this just is getting
from bad to worse for what that last move was
not it knight g4 was just a drop you need to
make a move my time is ticking i've got to do
something would have been better to play move h3
or king g1 but knight g4 there's no threat you're
you left control of the c4 square and allowed a
knight to park itself on c4 now it's up to fabi
fabi wants to find something nasty right now
is it a four i wanted to play a4 with the idea of
playing b3 but the opponent he does have the move
b3 himself so that's a little bit tricky what's
the way to to amp up the pressure in this position
i don't quite see it is it h5 chasing him back
no knight d4 finally just putting the knight on
a central square and chasing him backwards and
as you said robert he could double on the d line
yeah he's just saying i don't mind the trade
because your bishop still can't go anywhere and
let me go rook d1 next if you're not careful
and rook takes e4 was an immediate threat
it was an immediate threat indeed knight back
guarding everything there's no bishop h4 trickery
i want to force g3 but i want to do it if i could
play bishop somewhere else afterwards just just to
lighten up that diagonal for some tactics with
rookie for later but no if only if my bishop
could go to a great square on the next move but
i want to waste this tempo in this way because i
don't want white to have a free move after this
so the real threat it looks like is going to be
b3 robert where is the knight going to go maybe
she'll play a4 now and if b3 take and then play
knight back to a5 i'm with you there it softens
up the square you're gonna just go go right after
this pawn in many of these positions you can even
sacrifice an exchange as long as you get this pawn
so i i see that the evil bar doesn't look
oh my gosh knight d2 knight d2 in we go uh
i'll i'll take back my a4 and say he should play
knight d2 i mean knights normally don't land
on the seventh rank your opponent's second rank
like this just to park themselves there but oh man
this guy has got valet parking on the d2 square
right now look at that beast hitting the bishop
and prepping everything else i mean also by the
way opening the diagonal for his bishop on a6
the square control is marvelous i mean jeez
this is terrible where's the bishop going to go
and you know maurice we were focusing on a4 b3
you can even play c4 b3 if uh white allowed it
to oh this is he had to take he had to take her
but his bishop on c6 would have been atrocious and
now there's going to be tactics there's going to
be tactics in a position like this one but in the
meantime c4 more board control man fabi is playing
like a beast i mean jeez leave the guy alone bobby
look at these moosies dropping on him and now the
question is what's the killer blow the the knight
in f2 looks tenderoni b3 looks i mean that just
looks like it right doesn't that look like it
looks winning you just play b3 kick the rook
and then if the rook trades the second one
comes out hitting okay he just wants it all
look at the guy a4 domination make a move
and your opponent doesn't even know what you're
threatening necessarily can he play 94 now i mean
he's got to make a move he's only got 20
seconds left he's being completely owned
and 94 was totally forced and here comes those
pawns there's gonna be a passer real soon look
at this in comes a3 next and the bishops with
the pass pawn that's just game over and what a
gorgeous chess dominant chess amazing play wow
this is this is oh no this has got to be over
by the way bishop bishop b7 forces you to go all
the way back home because of a tactic and a3 is
going to happen anyway he's calculating a3 but
he only has 20 seconds left so he's got to find
the right path here and he did finally play it
forcing that piece back and what's what would
be wrong with a3 he's decided yeah you know what
i'm going to snack i'm going to go why don't you
play it right right right through just winning a3
was it is winning right now same thing right right
already b2 and the guy's going to be tied down for
the rest of all time and also as you said rook c4
is coming with rook c1 oh it's all yeah it's
complete bishop c5 for good measure now if you
want it rook c4 of course is just rooksy one next
rook c bishop c5 at the end bishop d3 holds b1
oh my gosh you wanted to see it i know you i could
see it was hurting you that he didn't actually
play it you wanted to see the move on the board
show it robert show it to the fans so they can
appreciate that finish bishop d3 trying to hold
but no bishop c5 and that's it rook f1 met by
a simple trade on f1 and then queening
3-0 to start this is just a straight
i told you he hadn't played his best chess yet
did i say he hadn't played his best chess yet he
was up 2-0 robert and he hadn't played his best
chess yet that right there was a master class
that was a master class what play by fabi
from start to finish just in flow 3-zip
wow and that's the problem maurice is when you're
playing somebody as strong as fabiano and you give
him that confidence we know he has not always
been the finest speed chess player in the world
but right now this guy looks unbeatable he has
made almost no mistakes with the exception that
first game when he didn't play d4 is black we both
were critical of it and deservedly so but since
then it's been all fabiano the entire way and and
do the shoes now all right we got a guy's a clock
world-class player he's 3 000 rated in in blitz
for a reason he's got to stop the bleeding we've
seen this happen time and time again he's got to
stop the bleeding right now get first of all he's
got to speed up look at it look at him the way
he's wiping his his face holding his brow he's
like yo i'm getting hit i'm getting hit you need
to stop the bleeding quickly get a solid position
trade off some pieces get a draw and maybe make
another one and then start playing chess because
right now if he keeps playing and if he gets
highly aggressive trying to get those points
back right away robert he could be down four
or five nothing and the match may be just over
well not if uh smarter chess's bullet
predictions come true with a 7-3 advantage
for duda and i love just arguing with smarter
chess predictions like my favorite thing to do
and as you see on the screen 77 favorite winning
five four in the five minute i don't think so
five four in this time control three nothing
fabiano right now predictions already off
that prediction we can already throw out the
window he would have to win the next three for
us to start saying it's possible it's you know
it's theoretically but like even in this position
i'm sorry but already i like white you tell me you
don't like the bishop pair because the bishop on
f6 isn't the most dominant bishop you've ever
seen well well you know i'm just going to say
i like white how does white now build on this
position positional advantage that he has and
again he's got to get back in business on
the clock does duda he cannot keep being
worse on the clock just you just can't
and fabi now just playing straightforward
chess taking and saying i got double pawns let
me go after your f6 pawn now this kind of play
it it's typical it's classical play against
weaknesses but black has shown that in these kind
of freshly called structures it's not necessarily
that easy to crack black's kingside so i'm not
sure 96 was the best way to play in this position
as i don't see white's natural follow-up and the
threat of d5 for black will be in the position as
well as night before and a rook on the sea line
so the queen leaving in this way after knight of
six queen eight six robert i gotta say i felt like
that exchange and maneuver may not
have been the best for black foreign
to demonstrate that i'm with you maurice because
the bind was more important to me than the double
pawns yeah you give black these double pawns makes
the king look less safe but you have to prove it
whereas the knight is doing a great job just
saying you're restricted completely this knight
before i do the mercy mention not available and i
can take you on f6 when i want to you do not want
to take on d5 that would be a choice that gives
white complete control because of this backward
pawn and this bad bishop on f6 so i'm totally
there with you maurice that taking on f6 it
felt like it relieves the pressure that black was
under unless fob you can prove it directly with f4
and i guess he's trying to play f5 g4 g5 and crash
through so you believe if you're white that you
are not going to face any counter play by the way
i don't understand why king h8 i would have been
aiming i mean he's decided to cover up on on the
side of the board where white is attacking what is
duda doing you just he just sees the defensive we
were talking about the counter play on the other
side you should have been thinking rook c8 knight
b4 if you're going to take on the on the b3 square
you know let okay you're going to do it
anyway so let it play is that f5 move
but right now this last maneuver i am not feeling
i think he thought he would be getting play mate
shouldn't fabi have been sacrificing in that
last i don't know i was thinking about being
able to play for bishop attack rook and
then pawn but now that i'm thinking about
there's a queen f8 defense that no queen of
face not a defense there's a queen of six
so i don't know it felt like there was a sacrifice
in there robert now black seems to have pushed
white back at least a little bit here although
i do feel like playing c3 and sacking my b-pawn
i'm with you c3 looks really strong to kick this
knight and give up the b-pun i'm gonna go back to
that moment just because we uh have the now
support option you wanted to kick this rook
right with some kind of like bishop h3 and then
just play g4 g5 and look i actually wanted to
play bishop to e2 but i'd have to i'd have to work
again with the next tempo so this this is probably
i mean this is what i wanted to do i didn't want
to just put my bishop on h3 but now that i now
that's clear let's play bishop h3 and play g4 and
ask what was black's next move against this very
direct demonstration f6 is hanging maybe
he could wait until g5 and then take and
play for i don't know it just felt like bl white
would naturally do this to get compensation but
it is a sacrifice it is your sent upon it's not
it's fabi's center pawn not mine so he's like nah
i'm not sacking it i'll get it later i'll get an
idea like this in time although i'm i'm with you
i mean this attack looks very strong but fabi's
saying hey those are not your pieces guys you
can sacrifice them but i have to pay the price if
i do it's right but it's your game you sack him
in the meantime he doesn't have to rush i mean
he can just wait here you see him just saying
let me be patient let me develop the strength of
my position and sooner or later i'm going to play
the move c3 trust me i'm going to kick that one
out then i'm going to play bishop to e2 and i'm
gonna kick that workout then i'm gonna play g4 and
the queen on c7 that that's not an attacking queen
that queen's gonna have to go back to e7 when
queen h6 lands on the board queen eight don't
think your queen is roaming your queen's not going
anywhere this is you know this is not sprint and
verizon you're not roaming there's there's going
to be charges to the roaming because the queen 86
the pawn on f6 will be untenable and so the queen
has to stick around because of that tactic that's
an exceptional point maurice the queen coming
back to h6 will force queen e7 so we know
that we can get a position with the queen on h6
and the queen of e7 but timing that is important
and i like this move by the way by duda with a5
because if he had not played a5 white wanted to
play c3 but probably wouldn't be four and then
c3 so as not to drop the pawn on b3 but a5 says
hey you're pawn's stuck here and you have to be
completely sure that c3 works otherwise you give
me a pawn in front of your king and then my knight
can back up to c5 that may not work out the way
you intended to so i like that duda played a5 it
also gives him the possibility to play a4 himself
to try to break open this a file at all cost and
rook g2 interesting choice i i guess he's just
preemptively defending here so he can put his
bishop on d5 all right but now we're getting back
to this queen eight six i the pawn on upon
on d6 is weak what about bishop c4 is that
there's still b5 miraculously because if bishop
d5 is rook takes g3 distracting your rook from
this square and uh that's a big point that's a
big point it looks like you're right although
although robert although hmm oh i see what you
should do you're trying to continue this line yes
king a2 very important so you don't take with
check and i think i take on d1 rather than taking
on g3 because if i take on g3 at the end of this
i see you're going to check this was the point
this was the point i was checking out like this
looks this is over we're just winning in this
position so you cannot do that and i'm sure he's
calculating wait bishop c4 is on the board oh so
this might happen but this is c4 is on the board
this is the high class trickery now are we so
what's happening here queen 86 does not work and i
think if bishop f7 there's like rook g7 maybe like
barely keeping things together i'm not convinced
that's clearly i would have been a queen h6 in
that position but then i'm gonna take your bishop
but you're gonna take my bishop and i don't have
a queen queen to line up on the g line that would
win you're right so what would i do here would i
back up and then just back up just threatened just
to take and start harassing you yeah this is just
it's just good your king on a2 is somehow safe and
the king on h8 doesn't look so safe is that true
a4 is coming though a4 if bishop yeah you're right
oh my gosh you have to move the bishop first but
eight this is too complex man yes that's what i'm
saying i don't know and b5 is on the board bishop
d5 on the board and we are there we are there
folks 35 sec both players at only half a minute
probably with a little bit of an edge but this is
duda's chance he is ferociously calculating rook
takes on g3 it feels like it's now or never
because c3 is coming next c3 is coming next
and then his knight is going to get chased and
white is going to say yes thank you very much
let's maybe even switch to the d line whatever it
is it feels like he needs to just play he's he's
backed up he's he's blinked he did not play the
move and he's played a4 instead deciding on this
line i feel like see take on a4 and play c3 robert
looks like the right way to go here maybe you take
this rook g3 so i mean he's tricking him into
taking on a4 so that when his queen gets to c2
out to a4 nasty point indeed that's a very nasty
point and instead he's played rook c1 oh he wants
to take with the pawn because the bishop covers
the a8 square which means you're never getting
your rook into the attack to make me that's such
a strong bishop but that knight on d4 is also good
white for choice now the knight on d4 yes the
bishop but i gotta like white here as black is
congested and now the king to g7 interrupting
the play where's that king going i think he
just needed to make a move and here he goes
queen to c3 and queen c7 and now they're flying
i'm not sure anybody's winning here rook
siete is the king is on eight six what
rookie come on now this is not real no way you're
surviving this position can you be queen c7 a
trade i think they're just blitzing now they're
not sure what's happening at all what's this oh my
gosh here comes the king this is dude his game g4
is a bad move g4 was definitely a bad move it did
not it was not correct but you know what right
around now it doesn't matter what correct
is because they're just blitzing two seconds left
three seconds both sides just go just going down
with no time on the clock it's winning for black
though knight g3 knight takes e4 he can just win
the pawn directly and just a threat and there
he goes and he's trying he's picked off a pawn
and due to using now the one second increment that
he's got will he be able to do it one second two
seconds left he's gotta move he's gotta move he's
worried about giving up this b5 pawn so he should
keep that pawn you want pawns on both sides he
breaks open the position now he's a past e pawn
this is it maurice this is definitely good and
there he goes knight attacking and he's gonna pick
off the pawn and now fabi with one last chance
but it's not gonna be enough because the e pawn
is also passed and this is terrible the pawn
will push b-pawn will push he's got too many
things he's got to deal with does fabi and oh the
knight on e4 guarding the critical point and now
big time trouble is he threatening to take bobby
has one chance but no he's too slow islam amazing
save by duda he needed that game robert badly
and he got he still looks like he's in the same
mood he's been the entire time barely kind of
moving his body just kind of there and that was
huge though that was really important for him just
to prove that he can beat fabian he knows he can
he's done it before but in this match fabiano has
been the more dominant two players and we're back
to this french and queen of b6 because the paul
went to a3 so that was the big difference due
to realizing he doesn't like these positions with
black kids before maurice are we gonna see d4 what
come on come on you know what the problem is they
don't get breaks they don't get breaks that where
they can their second on the side could say
hey hey next time you get this position you
can play d4 i mean they just don't get those
breaks and maybe they're seeing something that
we don't see robert we we ourselves we're not a
100 percent clear maybe they're seeing some deep
2 800 3000 chests that we're not aware of but d4
does look like a really good move in that position
i think that after into going to three minute
portion when they can look over their openings
a bit you know take a quick breather then we'll
start seeing fabi going for d4 much more likely
but if duda decides that it's a position
he wants to play again because fabi hasn't
uh hasn't probably won two games with black
already he has yeah i mean so you two both games
in the french they're discussing this french again
dude i might say it's time to leave this french
this french is hitting me in the head
the french are cheering as it looks like
black has done well both times although i remember
this last time when he was able to play the move
b4 and get his queen of h4 and get some stuff
we were liking white a lot and here comes b4
himself remember we said b4 was the idea for
white and bobby said i don't want to see that
again that was annoying so let me get this move
in myself before good shot get your play quickly
right you can't not afford to have dude i just
go on the king side like you did the last time
you need to open some stuff up here and so b4 he
wanted to take so his knight could have captured
on b4 and gone after this bishop on d3 but uh this
is smart by due to not taking on b4 allowing black
take on a3 trying to keep it close but finally
maurice we see d4 we see the bishop on b7 come
alive and how to prove it though yes we like that
bishop now but is it going to amount to much or is
white about to play knight h5 bring the queen in
and this poor king on g8 is about to get made it
okay uh look yeah he's don't get too excited
okay we're gonna deal with that right now he said
let me bring my knight back to e7 and then when
i'm ready i'm gonna kill your piece on d3 when
your queen lands on g about to land on g3 so i can
play knight f5 instantly at the same moment the
exact moment your knight gets to your queen gets
to g3 so knight h5 will be bent by now it takes d3
and then let's keep it going on the queen side
that's what five he's after because he's ready
with the knight f5 defense his bishop is beautiful
he's stopped knight e4 i'm liking black black's
done everything he wanted this is why we want to
play d4 robert this is the reason we wanted to
play d4 he got it in he's got b4 in he's got the
bishop on d3 on the threat bishop's beautiful dag
you know i think black's okay yeah and i res i
was in my temper tantrum that i had earlier that
he didn't play d4 maybe he just knows his line
better than i do and he's just saying i can wait
if you know i can get d4 in my own time and here
it just looks so nice for black the pieces are
very strong here this knight at some point
consider coming to d5 into e3 but of course
the d4 pawn will be hanging in many of these lines
but even bishop takes f3 maurice and then knight
to d5 bring this knight into these dark squares
it feels like black is the one first to the punch
it's very fluid right now it's hard for me to
give up my bishop on the long diagonal in this way
especially since that knight on f3 he's only
doing one little bit of work but look at this now
let me tell you i would very much not have gone
after the a-pawn in this case look at fabi said
i don't believe your attack and knight h4 on the
board is i don't believe you i think i can just
snack a rooney on this pawn on a3 and what attack
do you have are you mating me with f5 and company
i'd be scared i'm just saying i personally
would be scared having my queen with this
kind of excursion on the other side of the
board when the guy is trying to kill me
you're also opening yourself up to discoveries
from the uh enough memories of queen a3
then knight h5 and once i play queen g3 i'm not
only threatening mate i'm throwing bishop h7 check
thank you for your queen on a3 and
if you take on d3 in comes the rook
with tempo sliding over to g3 as
well and that looks like a problem
this is a whole this whole excursion looked like
a problem putting a queen on b2 that you know they
say when you when you're trying to win a pawn when
you go to win material it takes three moves the
move it took to attack queen b2 the move it took
to take queen takes a3 and the move it takes to
get your queen out of there anywhere you want all
right that's three home moves you give somebody so
dude i said okay knight h4 i'm thinking that you
know that's your attacking move you're gonna take
i'm like knight h5 that's my second move and
you can make some queen move queen g3 thanks
for the three free moves i'm on the attack i'm
threatening sax i'm after you so this is a really
delicate moment for fabie dropping that queen on
b2 and and and now he's played rook to c8 clearly
he's not taking an a3 pawn he's got to get counter
play before white winds up like a mike tyson punch
and knocks you out you know it felt like one of
those psychological experiments maurice where you
put some candy in front of a kid and they're not
supposed to take it right a3 was the candy but the
cameras are on yellow the marshmallow experiment
we're watching you don't want a3 you want to wait
you want to be patient and rook c8 lines up
on the c2 pawn because that's the much better
pawn to munch on here so if he can't take this
bishop and take on c2 that opens up the entire
second rank and the bishop on b7 comes alive
with a rook getting down c2 into the attack i
hear you talking i hear you talking robert but i'm
feeling like something better happened real quick
because the knight just landed on h5 and their
their guns are about to be aimed at black's
head queen g3 is coming on the next move the
question is is knight takes playable knight takes
queen to g3 looks like the intermezzo you got to
toss in there and then g6 this looks like what
has to happen and is this what's on the board
looks like it's on the board the game position
and now is black okay this is the question
and i can end up on f6 but is it just a lonely
night with no one else joining the party by the
way rook b1 rook b1 is yet another move to be
well wait a second wait rook b1 is met by by
oh it's blacks during the move so rook b1 was
an additional threat right rupee one was an
additional threat so he had to get his bishop
out of there and now does white have a blow maybe
white has nothing this is what he's calculated
that white doesn't have anything and that bishop
is going to be superior to both those knights
sitting on the side of the board and his knight
and h4 sort of has to stay here because you do
not want to allow knight f5 as that knight hits
the queen and also enters the e3 square so knight
f6 as you're suggesting and i agree with you is
just a check right my king can just go to h8 or
g7 and unless you can follow up very quickly with
your queen infiltrating then you're not getting
what you're you came for yeah the problem is that
white's rooks are not doing anything i mean the
rooks need to be planted somewhere but the window
of the attack that that attack window on the you
look on the on that king side it's so small there
are no vectors leading toward that black key
and i don't have six congratulations but nobody
else to join the party so this this night will
be its own lonesome like a covid attack on it or
something that's telling you know nothing going on
i'm telling you this position looks fine for
black he's okay he's estimated it quite well
no problems here the question for white is will
he let black start to wind up anything there's a
rook c3 that might happen is it rook c2 that might
happen and white has no penetration points nowhere
nowhere brook b6 who cares what do you do as
white maurice it's sad but what i'm thinking
about is knight d7 knight b6 just so i can get
this bishop off the board like i was just playing
defense i was like let me bring a knight with a
temple on your rook and then bring my knight to b6
with a shot on your rook and your bishop but he
plays knight e4 which does limit the scope of the
bishop but you can even consider at some point
taking and bringing this rook down to c3 and
going after this queen what do you mean at some
point right away that was a possibility right on
the board it was bishop bishop take looked like
an idea the problem is it does give white control
of the f5 square right that's what he just didn't
want to give him any chance of being able to build
on the attack because then the pawn is on e4 then
he could play for f5 and there's some initiative
there i'm gonna give him nothing like no nothing
for you no food for you let's just keep the attack
limited night on a great square d6 robert but
what's the deal am i not liking rook c2 here like
so is there f5 that's what i was wondering because
f5 you cannot oh there it comes if queen takes g3
you throw an f6 check into metro very important
move and if you take i take with my knight thank
you very much because after knight takes f5
your pawn is pinned and i win your queen so f5
was played i don't i don't get it why not trade
queens let you get that move and now uh the knight
can can find multiple squares for one c6 hits
your pawn but d5 also hello e3 is coming and all
your f5 f6 move did was block up the position
now you could dream about an end game this is
very important to note an end game that might be
better for white because the black king is frozen
that's why i wanted to try to work on that e5 pawn
and there he goes he's moved his rook off the line
so he can go after it but suddenly there's some
back rank issues in the position that that white
is trying to cook up and this is actually very
difficult for black with 16 seconds left both
sides in time trouble i think it's very hard for
both to play and look at fabiano very smartly
going for this g2 is it rookie 194 that's me it's
mate rookie one knight g4 knight f2 it's over
it's over he blundered rook he should have
moved his knight first he blundered rook down
and fabi stole the game look at that stunned look
on dude his face he was mr cool before this but
that stunned looking probably with a half a smirk
there as rook b8 blundered the back ring and as
you pointed out he spotted the mate as quickly as
you did robert knight g4 hello knight f2 your king
can't go anywhere mott on the board what a steal
by fabi and that's just the kind of form he's
in today right they you know people don't really
believe so much in luck and chess right if he can
continue putting the pressure on duda it's because
of that that dude is making mistakes and honestly
fabi had the better of the position you said it
clearly maurice the pawn in f6 it looks very nice
but it's not amounting to as much as it would
if you could actually create an attack and the
attack was too slow fabi steals the point i think
that duda has been too slow let's be real duda has
not been able to play incisively and get a lead on
the clock we have not seen him get a minute lead
40 seconds even it's fabi every single game and
if bobby continues to do that game after game
after game keep that edge on the clock dude is in
trouble and what's this position d4 this must be
some theory but look at dude he's shaking his head
his eyes i mean he's glazed over he's not happy
right now fabi with a 4-1 score now it's smart was
it smart chess that said fabio would only get four
points because he's got four right now he's got
four i mean the score was supposed to be five to
four five he's got four dude would have to win
the next four games in a row who wants to take
that bet right now um i don't think so the way
fabi's playing the way dude is not getting his
quick leads on the clock uh this is not
great but this last sequence tricky tricky
what is going on here is black just much better
i believe so rook d8 can pile up more pressure
on this pin piece there is c3 so let's count we
have one two three attackers on this d4 knight
and there are three defenders so if we can
remove one defender we win this game is there
a way to do that because white will try to play
c3 next so robert but the knight on the knight on
f6 can prance i mean knight g4 i'm i'm scared
as scared like look at this knight what the heck
i mean this is this is dangerous this is pure
preparation this is pure preparation and fabi
stumbled right into one of judah's positions this
right here looks like clean prep pure as ever for
black you will not see this position happen again
in this match it's not gonna bobby's out of this
one he's just following her into something and
doing it just what the doctor ordered for duda
just what the doctor ordered i'm i'm with you the
game is not over of course but on knight f2 isn't
that just there might be some knight c6 and queen
g7 stuff but at the very least knight f2 forks
these rooks here and that spells trouble for what
if he starts with knight takes d knight takes d4
maybe he's over a knight e6 maybe he's
over a knight e6 but i don't buy that
either i mean i just i don't believe it
can can black even castle queenside here
stop it oh my goodness that looks awful i it
just pins the knight and then the rook can't
move because then the night is lost here so it's
over actually it just adds another attacker you
can't protect it really does it's over it just
shut the whole thing down pure opening prep
dude needed this game badly due to neither
this game and fabi is normally the one
who falls for who traps people in these things
he's playing d8 instead leaving his king in
the middle after all you cannot move the knight
because of what looks to be rook d1 i mean unless
unless there's a trick of some is 96 possible
robert or am i just dreaming fantasizing yeah
i don't believe in myself but let's play it
what else are you going to do you're going to
resign otherwise what happens with 96 rook d1 and
you have to let's play knight f1 i'm just going
to try to get my bishop in the game and now if i
take you have queen g7 i bishop d4 and that's that
okay now we cleared the cobwebs that's the finish
of that so we got the story right doesn't work
doesn't work can't do it it's over this is busted
but i i'm with you though that is the best chance
that fabi has even though judah has way too much
time to fall for some sort of trap there there's
something funny robert sorry play the same line
again 96 yeah rook d1 bishop c1 okay oh it's just
a stop yeah just a joke takes on e6 queen g7 and
bishop d4 and it's still mate on b2 because of
the pin so it doesn't help at all that's mate on
the board chess sometimes has a sense of humor and
fabi's not going to find this one very
funny no he's not the one laughing here
so uh this is down a piece the knight is pinned
and what do you think if you're fabi you've out
to a 4-1 lead it's about t-42 do you just spend
the rest of your time calming yourself down do
you think he needs to just like take a breath
here losing with the white pieces is never fun
he thinks and this is what he does right now the
clock is ticking clearly he could just resign
and play the next game but what he needs to do
and what he might be doing right now is he's
thinking all right what went wrong here in this
opening let me work it out right now i'm going
to be playing the french next game that's fine but
what went wrong here and he's using this this time
doing the beth harmon thing he could be
looking on the ceiling right now going hmm
what am i what did i do where was the trap how
will i play differently next time how will i
improve okay got it and when that has settled in
his system he'll make some random move like 96 and
then he'll give up the game but this is
out no question about it after pawn takes
there's no move yeah as we pointed out this
bishop is not guarding b2 it just isn't
and duda probably will not sleep on this fact it
would be stunning if he did but no after queen
takes on g7 he missed it uh well the thing is
the knight could take on d4 i guess but he's
just winning the bishop one f1 so he just
he went for a different winning plan gotcha
but yeah i also was like wait oh but rook f8 let
me just take this because queen e6 is one check
and i think this is actually an important moment
for our viewers because queen e6 would scare most
of us because it does look worrisome when
your king's in the center you get a check
but if we get this check 97 blocks a knight
is a great defender it takes away your
remaining checks for your queen and now i'm
offering a queen trade wall up an entire row
uh that was really nice of you to offer a queen
trade while up a rook you're such a nice guy
offering a queen tray i'm glad you think
i'm a nice guy maurice we've been
friends for a long time bishop a3
oh so unnecessary but still so
strong so not nice so not nice
don't move the 97 now though
because then you drop your queen
uh you got no pieces to attack with white
is checking with one piece there's nothing
to attack with uh it was it was a good time to
resign before this he could have he could have
definitely just stopped the clock uh right now
uh is he just done an exchange at the moment
it is in exchange points it's in exchange for
three so he's somehow trying to finagle some
kind of attack but right now queen b2 mate
is a threat so you got to deal with that
b3 looks like it runs into queen e3 yeah
just for fun queen e3 queen d4 come on man
be nice some respect okay white should
have resigned a long time ago so this
this does allow queen d5 check to try to keep the
game going and maybe queen e3 would have been met
by queen d5 check as well i'll bring it up we'll
bring it up oh my goodness yeah maybe queen e3 was
queen i think is losing clearly queen d5 check
here forcing rook takes queen then bishop takes
e3 but back down with check and then give us the
f1 piece i mean it was over all kinds of different
ways so it didn't matter but fabi as i said in
for me i have i have a mentality especially if
it's a match situation like this but it's but
in particular you do this in tournaments as well
settle yourself settle yourself take time to
settle yourself and what fabi did taking that
long break i hope he spent time settling himself
i don't think he should have made any more moves
i think he should have accepted the situation
was bad forget it everybody's making moves
make them quickly but the key thing was to settle
yourself settle your brain and get ready for this
for the next game after this one say how should
i have played now we're seeing a new french twist
as fabias chased duda out of the line that he was
playing yeah he put a5 instead of a6 and b5 but
this pawn was on c3 so it's a different line all
the way back here because the knight had been on
c3 f4 knight f3 have been played but knight c
to e2 allows you to create this pawn chain so
that's why things are a little different here so
he did you like that when you chase somebody out
of the line that they were playing and say okay
go to something else maybe your secondary line
that you haven't prepared as well as a backup
line so fabi feeling good about that for sure
duda in the meantime has to settle things
down he doesn't seem to have an alternative
e4 what what to do so he's going into these
french positions straightforward and hoping
that he gets some play but at least he's settled
the match robert it is four to two at the moment
so he was getting blown out 3-0 felt horrible
4-2 on the other hand a bit different feel
in this and by the way how badly
is white doing in this match
not well not well at all right i mean white sounds
like this the score might be four to two white
i'm i'm not sure exactly what the numbers won
three wins for black because jkd just won with
black and fobby's won two games the black so at
the very least is three to three so i think fobby
won three games with black because he mated him
in that last french he won the first two french's
and he made it have been the last french that's
four two you're right three so four for black yeah
i'd say blacks black's doing well but hold
on what is the other game that duda won
dude just one with black what was
the other game he won did he win
why am i forgetting the game he beat fabi
he also won black in games he also won
it's 5-1 black right now it's 5-1 black is rolling
in this match unbelievable man don't want to have
the white pieces incredible so far in the match
and black by the way in this position also looks
good yeah this rook on h3 you need to sort of get
the sacrifice going take on h7 knight g5 all this
kind of stuff but i'm pretty positive fabi will
not allow that i wouldn't be surprised to see him
like f5 played to close down the king side and i'm
not even sure bishop h7 works i just know the idea
i'm fearful of it i do not want to allow it yeah i
hear you i hear you and it's got to be calculated
in every single move right now dude with a little
bit of edge on the clock as he's got in a complex
position this is a critical game folks this is a
critical game fabi breaks through and goes up five
to two uh he will almost surely win this portion
almost surely win this portion so this is a
critical game we see that there's only 20 minutes
and change left in this portion of the match
that's two more blitz games after this matter of
fact he may be lucky to get the second one in well
i guess he would say yeah they're two more after
this so that's this is a critical moment for duda
and fabio decided he didn't want to see any bishop
87 sacrifices get rid of that stupid bishop on d3
and just play chess here his bishop can i love
that maneuver you pointed out his bishop can go
back and what just happened so bishop bishop to
attack this pawn and the knight was in the way
so he dropped the knight back to a8 to defend it
with the queen man i hate moves like that me too
oh really you like you can have my pawn i hate
moves like that my goodness did he really have to
play that move probably not couldn't he play yeah
i guess bishop b4 looks lame also but i like that
i mean it seems seems preferable no i mean i
i don't know i just i hate moves like knight
a just to defend not only do you put your knight
on a horrible square you're not can't even move
right for starters and your queen is tethered i
mean it just feels like you gave a couple of moves
up but black might just be holding the position
together you made this point about the bishop
being able to switch diagonals from d7 to e8 to
the g6 squared that's not going to happen i'm
starting to like white i'm starting to like white
now it feels as though black must play for b5 must
must play for b5 at some point i don't know how
he's going to get it but he's going to have to
get some kind of play and knight back to e2
i'm not sure where that knight is going uh
there to stop your plan b5 is going to happen
at some point it can't happen now unfortunately
because the a5 pawn will hang with the rook on
that square so he's played b6 and now he's got
he's got a 2 whoa i was saying he's got a tortuous
path to his night getting in the game but g4 on
the board and duda feeling the confidence now
trying to make the big comeback robert man that
is a rambunctious ambitious audacious move it's
amazing how the position went from looking good
for black to a knight being on a8 and white just
attacking with a free hand so finally i don't have
to address these moments here because it's just
clearly good for what you have a great spatial
advantage your rook on h3 suddenly very useful can
come to g3 and play g5 you want to break open the
king side over here i mean king f2 can be played
bringing this rook to g1 what's going on by the
way the move knight takes d3 is looking terrible
right now yeah it just caused pure flow for white
queen went to d3 bishop goes to d2 and white is
able to just do a quick maneuver knight back and
trolley g4 knight takes is looking awful as an
exchange it looks solid but the bishop on d7
that's supposed to say look thanks for your bishop
i'm gonna use the bishop i now have to show you
why the bishops are strong but bishop on d7 sucks
i mean sucks the knight on c7 horrible white just
has all this space now all that said white still
has to find out how to to bash black's headed it's
it's still not easy to make progress here without
giving up some kind of energy to black and there
you go rook c1 not a move i'd want to play because
it might potentially lead to trades on the c
line but where does your knight go and
as soon as i said it then i went to e8
it doesn't have a future there but he's looking
the trade well i didn't like rook c1 because
when aside lacks space you want to trade so
black doesn't really have much room to breathe
and now if you can trade along the c file and
maybe get that b5 move in even if that costs you
a pawn you need to get your pieces active uh but
on the other side of things how is white crashing
through are you going to play g5 that may open up
the f file and there's a rook on a f8 that will be
happy about that will you play f5 but that could
collapse your center on the e5 score and the f5
square so it's not that easy for dude to crash
through but trading pieces on the queen side
doesn't feel helpful for him did not feel rook c1
i totally agree with you didn't why is your rook
on c1 we threaten the sack on c7 like what's the
point it was an empty move he played it quickly
and he had a minute lead on the clock we were
talking about how much time he needs to start
getting an edge on the clock and he blew it in
that moment and now fabi gets a chance to trade
the queen is on g6 it looks part trying to do
something but i'm not sure what it's threatening
i'm not sure the point at all in fact i'm not
now though what is the counter play for fabies
now said knight to c7 he's headed to the move
bishop e8 if needed get your queen out of there
that that trade on a c file did wonders for
black's position absolute wonders and it's only
getting better on every move it really is because
even if the eval bar says white is still doing
well it's so much easier to play for black you
have a sigh of relief your pieces are coming out
and now taking on f6 he's deciding how he wants
to do that rook takes f6 hits the queen that's
great but it also makes the rook vulnerable to
a quick g5 which will blast open the position
time he moved his rook back he heard you he
heard you i there's gonna be a bishop before
check at some point you know he wanted to play
knight a six knight b4 is another idea but all
of this is too slow and now here comes the knight
to the e5 square i would gift you my my bishop on
d7 if you wanted it if you want it please take it
it's all yours here i would play b5 and close my
eyes just please just let's get something going
even though i'm probably busted and here g5 on
the board okay duda has figured out how to pry
open that side of the board look at this attack
and actually a big problem reese is this bishop is
hanging because hgfg you can't take on g5 because
the end the line the bishop on d7 hangs once
the queen has to move out the way that's a big
issue for fabiano so maybe bishop e8 was necessary
probably down to seven seconds only on the clock
his clock is in precarious territory with duda
with 55 seconds and a raging attack it's bad maybe
bishop e8 instead of b5 was much better now that
we look at it but here the knight has been chopped
off the board white is just owning this position
at the moment thanks to the bishop on d7 and the
knight on c7 as the position opens up fatherly
with pure desperation taking on a4 and praying
that he's not dying on the other side but this
looks terrible yeah rook f7 h7 check is important
he goes 98 but even h takes an h6 and h7 mate is
coming it's just over it's just no way to fight
back and there it is a big time win for with white
by the way for duda in that game absolutely huge
i'm gonna bring up that moment because it's very
instructive by you maurice saying that capturing
on d3 releasing that tension made all of white's
development very easy because right here yes there
was the attack on the h7 pawn we talked about that
you can play f5 to stop it but bishop d2 is not
possible when the bishop's on d3 because the queen
needs to defend it but after trading here look at
how easy it was for white to develop everything
protect the queen side attack and then you had
a free hand over on the king side so you're
right maurice taking on d3 i believe that was
an inaccuracy a subtle one at first glance but
it cost fabiano the game well i have a rule
that i tell my students that the three f's to
trading it should be forced it should be forced
or fantastic forced or fantastic or else
it's going to be well you know the other f
all right that's my theory when i talk about the
three f's of trading and fabi felt it in that
position did not trade it wasn't forced it wasn't
fantastic so hey you know what fabi felt that
and uh he went down in that game here we see
duda going back into this line that got him
so much love and bobby's certainly switching
it up a little bit with a pawn sacrifice on e4
temporarily but now looks like he'll win his pawn
back yeah although i wonder if you take on e4 with
some kind of knight b4 hitting c2 hitting a2 it
could be quite tricky here for fabi to deal with
and it's perhaps a good lesson do you have to
take this pawn back right away can you leave it
there start with king b1 he does that and say
e4 is falling in the very near future well uh
there's some trickery here knight g4 is possible
preventing you from taking on e4 right away
and then maybe playing for e3 but that involves
not castling not getting your bishop in the game
that could be dangerous that could be very
dangerous trying for this idea with no
development but it looks it does look possible
white hopes to be able to take and he's done it
on the board queen g3 could even i was gonna
say bishop c5 but i forgot there's a knight
on b3 covering the square you'd love to play
bishop c5 and bishop takes b3 no that's too
much you can't give up your bishops and keep
your king in the center right so here we go
in this this is a dynamic moment as queen g3 has
been played and robert you and i played a blitz
game the last game we ever played we played
a blitz game for charity uh if you remember
that was it for children's cancer yeah right
there was a charity we played in and we played
an amazing blitz game i mean it was we had so
much fun in that game fantastic game you got me
but the critical moment that you mentioned was
taking a pawn that was blocking up the position i
don't know if you remember the game at all when i
when i took a pawn that was blocking up your play
and sometimes you have to leave those parts alone
and say i'm just going to go for other stuff
and i re i just got the pawn back in a moment
when i shouldn't have and this kind of situation
probably said you know what you can even save
your stinking pawn you want to play f5 right now
go ahead go ahead i'm with you but your pieces
will feel a little blockage bishop e2 is coming
and i'm just going to get free play i'm going for
free play there hitting your knight threatening
and f5 is on the board this contentious position
now by the way bishop e2h5 is playable will he
play h5 first as white or will he hit the bishop
e2 move first so all this is what fabi's looking
at trying to figure out what's the right way to
flow here because bishop e2h5 looks like you're
never stopping these guys from being in the
position so maybe he has to play h5 himself
so he can play bishop b2 on the next move well
there's got to be something because i see three uh
0.3 is the evaluation for white so i'm trying to
find what it is is there some kind of knight okay
nuance moves are not what the computer believes
in when it's giving this kind of evaluation night
i really want to play knight d5 to get my knight
in and force you to take me but bishop v2 played
still at plus one and a half so clearly still
good for white but so there was something bigger
is what we're saying something bigger was on
the board that may have knocked him out but
he's playing the way i wanted to play with this
kind of maneuver bishop and here's the deal you
cannot develop your bishop on f8 without some pain
you do have to calculate there nicely king to f7
some tactics are starting to float here man
what is happening it feels like a queen g6 weird
you know you know what i'm talking about robert
some bizarro tactics might start appearing on
the board even queen g5 with the idea of g4 wait
wait there's this crate this this is some sick
stuff i want my knights to migrate over there
as well but i don't see how to hit yet yeah i
didn't mean queen g6 right now i meant the logical
follow-up to an attack that ends up with such a
such a crazy idea but some things some things are
footy here how does white make progress robert
i'm looking at these queenside dark scores as
well it's like you have such good control on
this diagonal here that oh he's setting it up he's
definitely setting up a knight a4 hop into b6 and
not only can you go to b6 this knight can come
into c5 you want to chop down this bishop on e6
which is defending the light squares and queen
f2 it does open up your g4 move maurice that one
looks actually very tempting next because the king
on f7 is not happy to see a queen in its line of
sight well when you look at a position the first
thing you have to do is look at your pawn breaks
because pieces normally unless they sacrifice
like the crazy queen g6 sacrifice i pointed out
pieces normally cannot enter positions because
pawns are guarding squares so the only thing
that you look for the main thing that you look for
to compete to combat those pawns restricting your
play are pawn breaks so g4 is a natural pawn break
h6 isn't because g6 and black shuts the position
down but g4 is a natural one otherwise you have
to find out squares for your pieces where can
they penetrate and you pointed out robert the
b6 square you spotted the c5 square you spotted
those are key squares in the position that you can
get to if you look around you can scan the board
very quickly and realize you don't have anywhere
else to put your pieces you might play bishop d6
trade off this dark squared bishop and then
maybe double rooks on the d-line even after
all that you're wondering well if i could get that
if i could get that for free but he's able to root
d8 and start challenging that so those posts are
not great what we're looking for are pawn breaks
like a g4 move open up the game and then try to
smash your opponent that's what he's looking for
in this position right now and that's what duda
is starting to analyze what do i do about this
bishop to e7 looks like the most natural move
but he's worried about g4 and he spent so much
time on the clock while we've been speaking
that he's down under a minute this is not good
i don't care what the position is and he's
played h6 oh he wants that queen g6 to have
and he's saying i'm going to play h6 and
i don't fully comprehend what it does like
there was nothing coming to g5 at least now that
i'm seeing so h6 it got me real excited and what's
there's some bizarre am i am i spooking on some oh
you played g4 i mean yeah sure i i had a bizarre
tactical idea robert i put my queen on nah it's
too crazy forget it i'm not going to talk about it
i wanted to spawn queen on g6 and sack my
queen on an f7 bishop with bishop c4 check
maybe mating depending on what you do but it
was the idea is so fanciful it's not worth even
craziness talking about but here we go we have
this position here he's played this g4 move
and he's taken and put his king nestled in this
cubbyhole but he is down two rooks for my count
at the moment black has a rook and a rook on h8
these pieces are not working but how does white
take advantage of the moment bishop the bishop is
going to come to the e7 square and look at this
he's saying i'm going to go after your e4 pawn i
want the pawn your king as long as you're down a
rook i'm not down two pawns as long as you're down
the rook your rook on h8 i'm not down material
yet i understand the move h6 a lot more now he
wanted to prevent bishop g5 in the event of g4
because it makes white's life more difficult to
recapture these pawns but e4 is what the target is
and 30 seconds for black fabiano's plenty of time
he has a minute and 43 seconds he can calculate
now 20 about to be 20 seconds for black your kings
on g8 your rooks are not connected you've got no
development or coordination i think that this
should be a conversion for fobby yeah over this
is over this is blunder territory this is what
we're sniffing he just needs to to find moves on
every move fabi that's just like next on to the
next one on to the next one on to the next one
knight takes e4 what you dared you dare take on
h5 i mean should i be sacking on h5 right now
bishop bishop d6 head ooh i almost blunted i want
to go knight b to c5 to bring another piece in but
what have you sack on h5 now in employee knight
c5 i just feel like this must be an overwhelming
attack i cannot believe he survives this position
i would i have a hard time imagining that would
be the case here and i'm also looking at this g4
rookie one knight f6 kind of stuff happening yes
yes i feel you i like it i like it all of it looks
good there's some killer there's but the engine's
saying it's equal so we're we're getting out of
hand with all our ideas but i don't think black
defends this position and he's played my idea of
sacking on h5 i'm not sure it's any good he is
up a rook at the moment folks the king can't get
out yet but is is he crashing through he has no
bishop c4 because of bishop f7 so yeah did what's
the next move here is it one is possible too
queen b3 to take b7 is uh greedy did he take on
f8 he did that is the last thing i would have done
that isn't like that would have been out of but
that wouldn't have been even in my my purview
i wouldn't would have seen that move take it on it
you just you just facilitated the defensive setup
okay maybe he's thinking well rook to d7 and
eight seconds left and you know there's something
always going to be cooking in a position like this
bishop c4 what you got i really want to get knight
f6 after because when the king's on h7 the g pawn
is pinned but the queen defends f6 so you just
need to coordinate this so queen c3 is always a
possibility lining up for knight of six but now
yeah what was a3 i don't know i don't know you
can't be giving the guy free moves though just
go for it and now now king age seven and it looks
as though black is defending as the bishop cannot
get to d3 and black is putting up a wall eight
seconds left for fabi while we've been talking
unbelievable fabian spent all this time and
he's not figured it out knight to e6 queen
f5 and the moves are coming fast and furious
robert this is good for black this is great
for black and it's hard to play for both sides
of two seconds for fobby rookie fate played
king a2 the a6 pawn can be captured but that g
pawn is too wait it's gone as soon as i said it's
too strong here's quimby one coming by the trade
and it's one second they're playing on increment
only but it's duda with a time edge can fabi
possibly survive as moves are just being played
that that check gotta respond two seconds
and now he's blockaded he's got a knight
g5 idea eventually but this is bad no this
is awful it's just winning yeah the rook
is too strong for the minor pieces up in the
night's been trapped the knight's been trapped
duda pulls it off you know what i hate about
that maurice look at the score and the smarter
chess prediction was five to four in duda's favor
and you were saying dude is not winning four in a
row he's won three in a row and if duda wins
this game smarter chess somehow is correct
no he didn't win three in a row he won he won
four out of the last three out of the last four
because it was 3-1 it was 3-0 then it was 3-1
then it was 41. yeah he's won three in a row it
was four to one then it was no it's four isn't it
four to three right now is it four it's four four
what what where have i been unbelievable it
is four wow wow dude to putting it together
amazing i thought he had only won three
out of the last four he's actually won
those three in a row and the and smart chess
yeah making making itself look super smart
if bobby loses his game and goes down 5-4 the
final score will be dominant no question about
it duda is on a roll right now fabi fabi
did not win a position he should have won
absolutely and now things are looking bad it
should not be even he was up 3-0 the score
should not be either and have to give a nod to
duda because he was in immense time trouble his
king was on g8 his pieces were not coordinated at
all and yet he survived long enough to get fobby
in time trouble as well it was hard to find
a knockout punch and that's why he was able
to win that game and we have another french
maurice here different position to be sure
and instead of our typical uh setup that we've
seen time and time again we now have black with
the bishop pair the bishop on c8 not quite finding
a useful diagonal for the near future and white is
going to play bishop d3 going to make progress on
the king's side and it feels like judah's position
is slightly better what what's this last move
he's i guess he's figured out that bishop takes b5
it was impossible so king f2 and you you expect
from from black right now b4 and bishop to a6
to resolve this problem of this bishop
and then hope against hope that there's
no attack i think it's fair to say there's
no attack so time to trade off your bad piece
um he's a little bit worried about the domination
on the sea line however right and we've seen this
is old school classical domination along that line
uh go back as far as as far as alakine doing doing
the do with the sea lion i'm remembering some
great game remember that game where alakine
got so much domination on the c file and then he
doubled along the seventh rank and then he put his
king all the way in and you know the game i'm
talking about yeah who is it is it i'm remembering
margate is in my head for some reason but i can't
remember exactly but still you got to worry about
that c file and so he's decided not to trade off
because he needs to control the squares along the
c file and he himself has gotten control of that
line and it looks as though favi should be okay
here as he doesn't have any weaknesses white does
have space but black has his play as well and one
of the problems i would say is you were mentioning
bishop of a6 and you hear bishop b5 is possible
but white isn't going to trade the bishops he'll
slide his bishop back to b1 i imagine and try to
keep the attack alive on the h7 square and f5
is coming in the future i don't see how black
seizes active play whereas white's progress is
much more manageable to my eyes and i think fabi
he's doing fine but b3 just a3 lock that thing
up lock that side of the board up don't allow
black to crash through and it feels like white's
path just easy to see all right well here we go
spatial advantage uh trade-offs and pieces
the attack becomes a lot less likely now and
the issue really is going to come down to what is
either side going to do i would say this position
or the gm level super gm level especially
should be drawn uh doesn't look doesn't look
like there's real play here you make a good point
robert about black not having anything serious
along that line black does have that c2 point
so white has to be careful for that but again
bishop to b5 which looks like an auto move by the
way then bishop back to b1 and now rook c2 still
does nothing how does he get played as black given
that white is going to get his little action going
that's real i think it's i don't see a way to
stop white's variety of plans f5 looks strong
at some point knight g5 maybe next because if you
ever take on g5 h takes no no no your h file is
a disaster so i'm worried for fabi here and i
cannot believe i'm saying this after the start
that he had smarter chess i don't know how he
does it don't know how he gets these predictions
and makes them accurate but dude is well on his
way to a 5-4 lead and a victory in the five-minute
portion of this uh speechless championship match
tremendous comeback and by the way i believe
this last game started with less than a minute
left for this portion of the event so getting
in yet another game to get even get the chance
to make 5'4 as a number as opposed to 4-4 so
amazing i mean smart chess is that smart it
goes down to yeah there'll be like a little
time left for him to beat him that fifth game
and probably spending a lot of time now look
at the clock deficit at the moment as duda is
this is the kind of expectation we have for duda
is to get fabi in time pressure in the game and
then put the pressure on some more and watch fabie
crack under pressure and fabi has a tendency
folks and when he starts losing he doesn't
i mean i got to say it i just got a call
he's a friend of mine but i got to call it
he sometimes just starts to go
backwards he doesn't stop the bleeding
and and i'm talking about particularly
in rapid and blitz we've seen him do this
in a lot of rapid and blitz events where he
doesn't stop the bleeding he loses some confidence
he doesn't write the ship and say look i'm
going to draw a few games and settle things down
and he's done that right now and a number three
in a row might be four in a row in a second
if he doesn't figure out what to do queen c7 was
not a move that suggests that he had something
quick to do because the queen has nowhere to go
queen c2 doesn't do anything obviously there's
no sacrifice that's kind of fun and no just
nothing there so what is he supposed to do here
i don't know i guess he's trying to queen
a5 that looks like you're bringing all your
pieces away from your king and actually i want to
quickly say that what's been interesting thus far
is while duda has seen the stronger the two in
time scrambles fabiano has jumped out to a lead
on the clock in the early stages of the game which
could hurt duda in the three-minute portion when
you don't have as much time because fabiano's
openings have seemed a little bit better but
something about this french i wonder if fabi will
actually just deviate from it entirely because
in the last bunch of games where jkd has had the
white pieces he has proven an advantage and king
f2 talk about an unexpected move here maurice is
he trying to like go g5 g6 and then say i need
the g-file for my rook honestly i think he doesn't
know what to do and he's also letting fabi try to
figure it out i think this is a great strategy
246 left on the clock don't give your opponent
concrete problems to solve this is evil this is
evil chess i'm just gonna make a couple of moves
your turn and then i'm gonna make another couple
of moves and don't mess up i'm not gonna have
to try anything because you might mess up and
help me yourself so let me just chill let the
seconds tick off your clock pretty soon bobby's
going to be under 30 seconds under 20 seconds
with nothing on the board to do bishop a5 is
nothing look at that rogue g1 bishop b6 though
and rook c4 maybe try to get get an action on
the d4 square and then it broke d1 i had nothing
after that you see he made he spent a few seconds
and now if duda wants to now he decided i'm gonna
break with f5 rook c4 now you can just play rogue
d1 right now and now what seconds tick away going
off for fabi you see that what to do what to do he
may not be threatened with anything at the moment
but he doesn't know what to do and he had to make
a move and the seconds tick down now down to under
20. this is what i was talking about duda did not
have to do anything just like bobby make a couple
of moves play play defensively and you're just
in trouble and now you have six and it's over
this is blasting through perfect strategy this is
lights out as black has nothing to do here he can
think all he wants duda wins 5'4 smart chess
has predicted it unbelievably okay i'm calling
it before it's over but this is one of those
it's like biden winning the election it's over
it's done this one is gone and five to four just
like smart chess said an incredible role by duda
seriously i mean dude has played several excellent
games in a row he has a great handling of this
french friends from the white side and fabiano
needs to fix his openings because i don't think
he wants to keep getting into this battle in the
french yeah he's probably avoiding his main line
theory to save that up for his important can
determine whenever that resumes but maurice
before we go to break what recommendations would
you make to fabi if he's going to win this match
better faster he cannot his instincts have left
him i feel something maybe maybe you need some
almonds maybe some almonds and some raisins
because you feel the energy sucking out of
his game he's slowed down it's not only duda
is rising in strength duda is feeling himself
and playing with flow you've got to
break that flow and you've got to play
fast maybe you change up openings for a couple
of games i don't think it's a real necessarily
an opening problem as dude has shifted up
himself but he's got to get back in flow
speeches is not about opening theory it's
about flow and you can feel the energy out
of fabi right now i think he thought he was
going to roll in this match when he was up 4-1
it's on it's on he's in trouble it most certainly
is and well the player is going to take a break we
will do the same and for those of you who
are subscribed to the chess channel enjoy
this primetime smackdown i'm not even sure
who's playing but it is definitely going to
be a good one so we'll be back in a few for
more action from the speeches championship
hey man you ready i have never been
readier for anything in my life robert okay
you do sound really excited and
it's making me into a little concern
i am excited it does not capture the extent of my
emotions at the possibility of kicking grandmaster
hess's butt oh that's what i live for all right
well when i get at least one upset victory don't
cry okay just just just so we're on the same
thing you're talking about hypotheticals here
i don't like hypotheticals i like reality and
let's see what the reality has in store for us
well let's see if any of my studies of your
bullet games will help out darn i thought you were
i thought you would do something random you know
make a bad free move i think i'm going to play it
alpha zero style my position is already terrible
okay we we know that we know that we all get
you no i mean you're a good player i'm i'm i'm
not going to deny the facts here wow oh i forgot
you could your bishop or queen could go back to b2
okay yeah i can go back to d2 well my queen can go
other places other than those two stars true true
i i invite you to castle short oh queen d7 okay
you you told me i told you and you did it okay
that's that's the kind of relationship i like
i mean you know we're we're buddies i
just try to be we are yeah i think my
position is not bad let me get i don't
i think my position is pretty darn good
do you uh well we both clearly robert we have
a disagreement here we both think our but dr
san credit likes this position too well that was a
nice move and it was it oh thank you did you seven
my gosh leave me alone that ain't the only square
that's hanging everything's a problem all right
and i'm gonna take this one too that's what
they're gonna do in north carolina all right all
right all right i got this you missed that you got
this i know this is all falling into my plants yes
i this is all of this i'm gonna be honest
with you this doesn't we're gonna take this
or feel very good for me now we're going to okay
let's not miss checkmate though let's go here
here um okay now let's oh queen h2 mate devil
oh my god i missed him no i'm gonna miss that
i thought you might honestly oh my i almost
did i i did not play e5 to prevent that threat
i'll be honest with you yes you did come on
don't make me feel good it's like oh my god
oh you want to do this oh crap
oh you just fell for it let's go
all right let's go down here let's go here oh wait
how oh rook h5 i thought i'd just get you on top
oh okay i got i did cut that a little bit
too close i will admit i feel like i almost
had you there that was a nice trap in the end
i have yeah you're caught off guard okay okay
it's looking really ominous especially given that
he's down on time but this is the magnus carlson
squeeze um wow and knowing you don't get many
winning positions against magnus carlson nobody
does nicara's playing in front of hundreds of
people imagine being in his shoes right now
wow unbelievable up by four games
well i can resign yeah carl knows
it it started with 16 players and uh it all
came down to one man magnus carlson who won
this is a pretty great match i
know people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's a beast
an absolute monster it has been hikaru's speeches
championship this 2018 in car nakamura the overall
1c takes it home in the species championship
honestly these guys have played each other
so much obviously this is a rematch of last
year's scc final what a finish by the way
i mean that's been the story of the match
nakamura has just kind of out swindled out tricked
and out calculated wesley in the critical moment
dude that's a nice move wesley's shaking
his head ikaro wins the pawn he's gonna
draw this game i can't believe it that happened
unbelievable karo nakamura holding that position
and as we return we want to remind everybody to
get involved with guess the move no surprises
here i am dragon b70 is the top guesser for
the game uh one of the games we just saw and
get involved because the top three premium
guesters will win cash prizes and if you're
not a premium member you will win premium
membership so that's a good deal for you
and well speaking of guessing things correctly
oh gosh it pains me to say this but smarter chess
was correct five to four and i think maurice
that fabi just wanted to help smart chess out
he knows it's a tough environment out there um
you know finding a new job won't be so easy so he
went from a 4-1 lead into a 5-4 deficit well
you know pollsters have been having a tough time
lately as you know but smarter chess seems to
be the one they need to go to like if you want
to find out about chess and maybe presidential
elections whoever's running smarter chess might be
the man because right now that was a precise
guess 5-4 was indeed the final result and came in
under the wire because student needed to have
yet another game and there were only seconds
it seemed like left for them to start that
ninth game and make it possible to go 5-4
fabi's got to be devastated right now
and i see the next prediction to be 5-5
i don't know you lose four in a row sometimes it's
not the score it's how you get to that score and
he got to this score by losing four in a row he
was a 4-1 come on you lose four after being on 4-1
the momentum might have shifted already will fabi
find the energy to come back and make this match
as competitive at least at this
phase as we think may be the case
well we are about to get the games going and fabi
in the three minute plus one second increment time
show we just saw five five is the estimate and at
this point i think that jkd does have the momentum
and we're getting another one of these sicilians
where fabiano has had some good positions
but duda was very sharp he was alert when his
back was against the wall in that previous game
and maurice once again we're in this line well
duda is making the move h4 look ridiculous
i mean every position we've seen so far he's just
making h4 that's supposed to be the super fancy
move he's making it look completely ridiculous
it's like yeah i'm getting a good position every
time you can play four if you want to but i know
exactly how to equalize and now we see this line
up here on the on the board and duda has more time
than he started with he's still in his preparation
in the world did we just see like knight
is pinned knight takes e4 okay i you take
my queen i take yours queen e3 knight takes
so he gets it off the door knight takes d5
saying i don't want my piece back this is pin
there's a discovery here there's a rook on d1
in your queen so this is all some kind of theory
that duda knows really well because he's up on
time but this is a problem maurice right where
both players they know the first stages it's who
is going to be able to output the other from this
point because it's not game over it says zeros but
you have to prove that it's not just a quick draw
well the problem is the liquidation factor has
come very quickly and now you're right it is not
going to be just an easy draw from this position
black has to stop and think bishop c4 was a nice
move just add a little bit of extra tension to the
position remember when that bishop got stuck
on f1 in that nasty game where it never moved
now the bishop is in the game white has clean
development and the h-file so if you want to
castle queenside you're gonna have to think about
castle kingside excuse me the other thing about
the fact that that h file is open so b5 trying
to force the action and i'm seeing this bar go
completely nuts on this last move it's got to be a
knight e7 move though or is it a knight six moves
look at knight f6 yeah it takes an e7 probably
even better according to this keeps the advantage
and what does when they come back to f5 this
bishop's pin otherwise i could just take you well
what's wrong with is queen takes is it just going
to be a straightforward capture capture though
that doesn't seem oh maybe you just need
to pick off oh you can't oh it's night it's
knight d4 at the end take and play knight
d4 you can't castle well those are good
there's queen e4 here too maurice hitting
you in uh all directions oh that's nasty
i mean something has to be winning here but
doesn't 94 no queen e4 looks really good he
can be one for real and it says stills is plus 4.7
well you can't castle you can't cast it because
the queen to d3 oh that's some g3 is nasty so you
just you can't castle so he's playing a move where
he just put his king away and he said okay your
turn if you can't castle the most natural move
on the board isn't possible it's unlikely you have
a move here your position's just too terrible and
there's no bishop f4 checks because putting
the king on the light square over here means
that if you do castle and the queen comes to d3
there's no sudden checks on the king so king b1
is that calm move and that's where the evaluation
mark can be tricky because you and i are looking
for the direct knockout and five says hey i'm comp
cool and collected i may have lost four games in a
row but i know how to play some mean chess and
i mean i don't think our euro queen e4 was bad
i don't think knight d4 was bad i think king
b1 is great i think white's just crushing
this position as long as you cannot castle
this is trouble now queen e4 does allow
and he's playing look at this way off center
move knight to a5 what a strange move it was
threatening very concretely this knight move maybe
he needs to play i mean he's gonna play knight b7
knight b7 maybe queen e4 and then knight
b7 right how can black move here just
feel like i'm trying to figure out i'm trying to
figure out the problem is having so many wins and
white's clock starts to tick it seems like it
seems to me that you play queenie for your move
and wait or queen b i mean there's too
many options there's so many options but
that's why i say you make the practical one
you play queen e4 he cannot castle rook h7
is a threat right now you cannot play queen takes
g5 so there's a threat on your pawn you can't take
on g5 because your bishop is hanging knight c6 or
knight b7 is coming there's got to be a boss move
it's got to be a boss move look how
many threats it's a centralized queen
and there's nowhere like what whatever you
move there's a move for knight c6 is coming
there's just too many moves right and queen
c7 can't do that because e6 falls with check
it just feels like the queen guards c2 by the way
on top of it there's no move there can be no move
a chest wouldn't be fair if there was a move it
wouldn't be logical and now this move e5 creating
a second weakness another weakness on this square
now isn't h7 hanging if i just take it that's just
one i don't even want it but it's possible to
take it it's also possible do what he just did
g6 don't castle because if rook takes h7 and mates
are coming around your king uh actually we can
just start with queen d5 check and then you'll be
done so castle says out you got to play this move
and now ooh stop it look at one you got four
seconds left to defend this monstrosity of a
chest position he's just traded and now
his queen can penetrate if it wants to
this is over yeah queen b7 looks like it does the
trick i mean where's this rook going it's under
attack the bishop one d6 is still hanging queen
g4 getting into e6 while attacking the queen e6
and queenie six is is also lights out as you
said that's that's done no moves a blast of a
win for fabi coming back that quickly and
just overwhelming him that was dominant
chess robert that was dominant dominant chess
and we saw them blitz out the opening right
three minutes and four seconds after something
like 12 moves and we see zeros on the eval bar
but the position is so complex with that open h
file the king of the center i wonder if duda will
go back to that line i mean he must because he's
been playing it this entire event but fabi saw
something right he did some quick glossing over
his openings and he saw something that he liked
but but you know what that bishop c4 move it
was really well timed let's let's be honest
bishop c4 was really one time but b5 has to be
the culprit b5 was the problem you don't have
time to play a move like b5 b5 said go ahead do
your worst and boy did he do his worst on him
like bang in your face so b5 was a huge blunder
in that position does duda does duda know what
to do about this the next time he sees it because
it was his preparation it doesn't matter if you
have preparation sooner or later you're going
to see a position you've never seen before your
opponent's going to play a move that the engine
didn't suggest and you're going to be on your own
and you have to figure it out and he doesn't
have time to go to the side and check his engine
or get a second to say hey dude you should
have next time you see bishop c4 do this
so that's going to be challenging for him and
maurice i have to say we are not seeing the french
anymore probably know the black pieces played a
king's pawn opening so e4 e5 and here we are in
the italian game but the knight went to h7 just to
move ago knight h7 that caught due to by surprise
he spent 27 seconds to play b4 and after queen of
six he had another 34 seconds playing d4 in fact
sacrificing a pawn in a standard manner
because white will likely throw the move e5
with the king in the center to be very careful
before you upon grabbing the center with your
king uncastled these joko pianos with these weird
night maneuvers have been so weird let me just
use the word again been so weird knight knight
g8 we've seen knight from f6 king ha knight g8
in a position where you say you can't
do that the laws of chess say that the
the central position will open up and you'll end
up in trouble you can't get away with maneuvers
like that and concrete computer analysis said oh
yes we can actually we can do it no problem at all
and so black trying for his play b5 though
concrete threat by the way uh li this a-line
might open in a weird way as well i'm using
this word weird robert what could i get
another adjective please i mean it's unbelievable
obscure i'm an english school i'm an english major
and i i can't go with another word trust me i
know you have a very extensive vocabulary so
you don't need to convince me but not today well
that's because things are weird things have been
weird right it was four to one then it was five to
four duda and now it's five five and we're getting
new openings and bishop back to e2 so i have a
lot of experience in the black side of the italian
and these kind of atypical night maneuvers
now i'm using the new word uh bringing the
knight to h7 to g5 it makes sense but white
does have the big center so the knight on a5
not exactly thrilled to be there that's offside
here knights on the rim we don't often like those
but how do you make progress from white's point
of view i guess that's the essential question
and finally castles after years of research
he finds castles as the deep move well
we've got this position as you said how
does white make real progress you don't
want to open up the line for this bishop
on a7 that bishop sits there and waits
and waits and waits and it one day wishes
hopes that you will capture so that he can do
some damage on that f2 square so white says okay
i'll make one more waiting move bishop a3 but now
we got your threat of taking on e5 we'll move out
of the way and what's your move now queen c2 now
this knight that's on g5 it doesn't really want
to trade for the f3 knight doesn't really want to
solve this problem it would love to go back to e6
and keep assailing that square d4 and looking at
the f4 square okay but he decided i was i was
wrong so i'd like to go for this trade on f3
as a better way to play the position i'm a little
surprised by that by black but it still looks like
he's fairly equal here the 96 move would have kept
the tension robert this by black is saying i'm
not worried i think i'm still going to be okay
although right now for me that knight on a5 is
culprit number one right that's why i'm looking at
c5 here as a way to stop white from doing the same
and to challenge this bishop immediately but
you're right this knight is stuck out here
and if i can line my queen up on c3 that knight
could already be a goner so you have to be very
careful right now if you're fobby c5 doesn't
look great because you mentioned the bishop
hitting the f2 pawn playing c5 makes your bishop
look worse in addition to your knight being
trapped over here on the rim so and what i
don't like about the situation it's probably
being down to 35 seconds and ticking we're still
in the opening this is we just left the opening
like literally just left the opening and now we've
played this move c5 we've buried if you look you
said bury this bishop and we haven't solved the
night problem the knight still has years years
into the future to wonder when does when do i
get back into the game guys like what's the deal
you might have to rely on some kind of bishop
f3 rook d4 even if it costs you an exchange
it's a thematic exchange sack with a rook d4
movement that's why i put the bishop on c7
is hey if you take me on d4 my bishop can open up
but for the time being fabi trying to sit on the
position but duda up 25 seconds nearly it's still
tense because there's no breakthrough just yet
and i'm looking at both sides maurice rook d1 rook
d5 and for black rook to d4 who's plopping a rook
down on the d file first and knight back i think
that black was relieved to see what just happened
no question about it and now a capture and b6
and he's at least got a path back to the b7
square but guess who has a path to d5 here comes
the knight and oh boy this ain't going to be fun
night on d5 well maneuvered there and
black's pieces look a little silly
the knights not the knight's not facing
any difficulty on on the a5 square and
he looks like he's going to play the move f6
at some point to try to shut everything down
he needs to do it quickly knight back trying
to get the knight into the game make sense
maybe this will come to a3 just trying to take
over the a file and strategically black is lost
but it might not be so easy to get that knockout
punch and that's really where the issue will be
for uh jkd and oh down to ten seconds almost for
both here this is the time scrambles requests
total time scramble and he's taking over the a
file himself no real threats for white so black is
hanging in there and i just want to play f6 i
don't know why he wasn't played a long time ago i
just i just want to play the move f6 but now bobby
understanding that at time pressure it's all about
just making moves all about he's making moves and
he's threatened something defense root back and
just make a move just keep going it's just can you
take on c4 i mean b2 is hanging in many of these
variations so you're calculating lines robert
they just want to repeat they just want to repeat
just probably just moving rook rook play of six
already fabi just make the move and get a solid
position stop looking for reasonable ideas three
seconds four seconds left can they last robert
this is crazy i know it is the 95 is very strong
but that's all that you have for white right now
the real coming watch out for doubling on the
first rank that would be devastating looks like
they may be trying to flag each other i mean bobby
doesn't care he's repeating moves unless he sees a
threat and now he should play f6 he's finally
on the board and he just should repeat just
this is ridiculous neither side knows what to do
exactly so they're just pushing things around h5
on the board g6 at some point probably necessary
but you're right i mean they're just trying to
figure out how not to lose on time at this point
he just looked like he hung the but now c4 is
actually hanging oh no two pieces are hanging in
this position but he's playing knight f7 and he's
just dropped a piece he just dropped a piece bobby
dropped the piece and now he's lost now he's lost
there's the game unreal oh my gosh and if that's
any indication for what we'll see in bullet then
fob is in huge trouble because there is that
one second increment which gives you time to
think a little bit to regain your composure bobby
never was able to do that granted that judah's
position was better from the very beginning
he had control over the board sorry robert
put your knight on f7 leave your knight on
f7 play rook a2 rook a4 rookie tour k4 until
the guy threatens it was totally irresponsible
what he just did what he was did was irresponsible
and in a blitz game no way and here we have this
position again bobby just blew that game in when
you're down to those last few seconds and you
have a mechanism for making repetitive moves
that's what you do i remember my my friend william
morrison they call him the exterminator i don't
know if you've ever heard of him robert but he's
a new york product straight out of brooklyn and he
had one trick winning time pressure keep your rook
close to the clock wherever the clock is and keep
moving when you have a situation you can repeat
moves keep repeating moves near the clock where
you could you can hit your clock and just keep
repeating the move short short moves with the rook
rook a2 rook a1 if you have to and just be right
near that clock and just do it over and over again
same thing applies in this situation he
had rook a2 rook a4 there was no reason
to deviate from that and he ended up losing a
piece and the game and now we see the same line
duda seemingly has done uh a little bit different
in the line but i'm not sure he's improved his
prospects dramatically and here's b5 on the
board again there has to be some kind of issue
with this bishop on d6 hanging i was already
look they should d wait what this what is this
legit there may be some kind of bishop takes b5
check and queen takes d5 is that i think he's i
think he's lucky if that's happening before
he didn't plan this oh he did not plan this
he is fortunate that this is on the board and
duda is looking at it like what are you for real
i feel like this is somewhere in the fabi
files like this you don't play bishop back
to d3 hanging the knight he could have spent more
time it said he spent seven seconds when bishop
d3 and then went rook to d4 and he's getting his
piece back oh watch out for bishop before though
you might you you better hope you get your piece
back because there's no r5 just yet and king b1
there's a bishop h our bishop
b3 sighting solving that problem
except the bishop on e5 the bishop on on d6 is
still a problem even on e5 it could be a problem
i i don't know why did i don't think this is the
favi files robert i disagree i think fabi is now
on skates and hoping that it works out for him he
can throw in the check he does that to get make
sure that his queen isn't getting pinned when
the bishop comes to f4 and this is under attack
bishop e6 there's rook takes d6 because if queen
takes always look if pieces are on the same line
each other move the piece out the way that's
between them bishop takes b5 check will scoop
up the queen on d6 so there are tactics here
that will regain white the piece and queen e7
was played rook takes d5 and i see the eval bar
off the side here saying white is just cruising
that's incredible what just happened i mean from
oops oops oh wait a minute i'm back in business
this is amazing the bishop on f4 and the knight
on g3 do not compete against the developed pieces
that white has and black is down a row black
is currently down a rook on that square has
a lot of problems to solve we've seen this before
will probably be able to make the breaks he needs
to get the big advantage in this position and i
do feel something weird about this knight on g3
that bishop this construction this constellation
of forces is keeping him afloat but something
feels weird and now g6 oh man something really
feels strange here if you could somehow play a
rook d7 and a bishop c4 and maybe c4 first
there's actually rook d7 and you can't play
king g7 what's wrong with what's wrong with that
i'm just going to show that you can't play king g7
because you walk into a pin and lose a piece
rookie 7 looks great rook d7 is bishop takes
on g5 you have to calculate and he actually is
giving up the g5 pawn because there's rook to g4
hitting both pieces here so fabi fighting but if
rook b7 right now right if fabi probably played
rook d7 so now the the problem is this this is
what i was asking right what exactly is the point
well he got this way in the best possible
continuation is this the live position
yeah he brought his rook to d4 to challenge the
mission my bad so he found this attack well yeah
no it's not your bad i mean it's good to
illustrate rook d7 is the natural move
but that he drops his rook to d4 to challenge the
bishop kick it to a worse square and if it takes
there is bishop h force exactly exactly i'm not
i'm not necessarily a fan of the two pieces here
although it's although that night let me let
me check me switch that yeah it's good that
knight on c5 is a monster and you just need b4
to cement it and that's done and the a6 pawn
with the b5 pawn and the bishop but there is a
three to one on the other side so there will be
counter play three to one i'm looking at a4 right
now to scoop off the a6 i think yeah just gotta
be aggressive gotta be aggressive on that side go
go go he's gotta run and now he wants to take on
a six he doesn't want the a4 pawn he wants to
take on a6 and then the b-pawn will be a beast
this looks winning yeah two on none on that side
of the board and oh don't allow rook takes c5 with
your bishop hang that's the one tactic you do not
want to overlook here uh yeah that's not going to
happen no and here goes the counter play this is
what he wants this counter play on the other side
an interesting move rook f3 saying will you play
rook f5 you think you're going to be holding this
position down not going to happen and wow a3 on
the other side of the board i think you can just
safely sit your king on a2 but i guess the point
is if you take on a3 we liquidate and maybe there
is some chance with h3 and rookie three check no
rook g5 is the issue but he's played bishop f1
to prove that this idea does not work this idea
does not work you sacrifice your opponent for no
reason and now all white has to do is move the
knight and start pushing him baby and this is
going to be a big problem yeah though this g2
pawn is a bit of an issue as well right bishop
e4 there's f5 a very tiny are you worried about
the g2 pawn robert i can play b5 you really want
this pawn i guess you're right i i'm just making
sure my opponent doesn't queen but bishop e4 noun
bishop exactly bishop and you have to spend
years trying to figure out i mean b7 b8 is very
compelling it's very compelling like that's that's
for real i buy it b7 the knight d7 just loves the
game lights out even knight a6 wins but 97 gets
the job done and those pawns aren't going anywhere
fast enough they are not nearly quick enough i
used to play a game with my students bishop versus
three pawns just the bishop versus the three pawns
in this case we have a knight that's coming back
there's no chance there's no chance you're not
getting anywhere as the knight bounces back way
too fast oh and what did he do what you had to
bring the knight back is he's still okay all right
he's guessed that it's okay but that means duda
made a mistake because it said zeros for a hot
second there i there was i don't know maybe the
the engine was just a little too exuberant in that
moment but now look at this beautiful formation
of knight and bishop shutting things down harmony
scary position for a second there
was it true that it was a draw
yeah we'll bring this up on the analysis board as
the next game gets started but also i think that
duda needs to stop playing this sharp sicilian
because fabiano has the better preparation that
we've been seeing in the last couple games
we've been seeing it we've been seeing it but
let's see so f4 must have been the move here
just try to play f3 and get this pawn going
boy he should have brought his i think
he should have brought his bishop
but you know what i'm not even sure what the right
move is instead of c4 now that you look at it
i don't know so see because you can't this is
exactly the game you play once the pieces get to
where they would get to maybe knight d4 but knight
d4 allows king e5 so bishop h1 f4 anyway knight
back not really sure what the move should have
been that's going to bother me for a while until i
figure out yeah i guess the uh you know there was
something there we'll maybe try to take a look at
it later but dudeo with two seconds on his clock
wasn't going to be able to play perfectly nor
was fabiano who had the advantage and let it slip
for just a single move there but maurice six six
fabiano so far in the three plus one he has two
wins to one and we should mention there have been
precisely zero draws in this match incredible no
great point robert incredible 12 games 12 decisive
games on that and by the way white won that game
so the string of black victories has been righted
somewhat as we've seen white win some games
now wow what a match this is awesome stuff
this is awesome stuff and you know it's
dead even smarter chess had had duda with a
a game edge after this portion he's still on his
way that possibly could do that but saying he's
going to dominate in the bullet and this is going
to be dangerous for fabi because if that's true
bobby needs some lead right now like now he needs
to start picking him up and putting them down
right now get some wins but they've traded punches
in the last three games haven't they they have
indeed and i feel like fabi feels that pressure
because look at the openings he's choose he went
away from the french it wasn't working for him
now he's going to the black side of these italian
games and he's going for the more aggressive lines
of the pawn on g5 and that's a double-edged sword
on one hand those pawns can help you launch
and attack maybe a g4 or king to g7 and f5
type of pushes on the other hand you're creating
weak squares in front of your king and that can
really backfire and that's why duda strikes
in the center so quickly here so funny though
because black had won so many games and then
white's just won three in a row yeah in fact
might have even won four in a row four yeah the
last game of the um the five minute was one minute
it was also a win so white has one point in a row
we're like look at black black is rolling and now
white is like bing bing and by the way this has
also come after they changed up a little bit in
the opening so fabi changing from the french this
last game has not helped him no in in in this game
as well he's down quite a bit of time here right
30 seconds and it's kings on g7 there's some
openness to it but i'm not buying the evaluation
right now so sometimes maurice we look at it as
grand masters like okay that makes perfect sense
here it's still such a clogged messy position
and i see some potential for black eventually
playing with the h5 and h4 with an attack on the
king side so i do believe that white is probably
slightly better especially now that i'm looking
at knight c4 ideas but perhaps there are some
potential for black but now that i'm looking
at knight c4 i'm actually just loving white's
chances and robert i'm going to say this too
i'm not seeing flow from fabi let's check the
time in this position four seconds five seconds
six seconds seven seconds it's a three minute
game you just went into a deep think it's ten
seconds have passed you're still thinking you
saw duda just made his move in about four seconds
he's still it he's still at it it's still going
it's a three minute game you don't have 20 plus
seconds to think on each move i'm not feeling that
flow and he's still at it come on dude you're now
under a minute and in crisis already this is not
what you should be doing in this kind of time
situation it's just this time control does that
punishes you it punishes you for spending this
kind of time and soon he's going to start making
mistakes i don't care what movie comes up with
i don't think it better be a genius
move it better be winning by force
because f6 after all that thought that's
not the kind i mean that's not it that's
not the move where you thought you should be
spending all that clock burning all that clock
for this is my problem and now night back
looking at those weak juicy like squares
not feeling what he did and look how quickly he
played 93 a practical move quickly and again how
many seconds have passed before finally dropping
his bishop too many but maurice i think this is
going to show that what i considered a double
edged position is not really so double edged
after all clearly duda has the advantage here and
white's pieces are superbly placed control over
the light squares as you're mentioning the king
on g7 not looking so happy so maybe i was looking
for hope because i play the black side of the
italian and not so much the white side but this is
not very pretty this is ugly this is absolutely
ugly and here's the deal when you trade off the
dark square bishops when you are playing a chess
game and you trade off your dark square bishops
that means you have an extra piece that can
control the light square that your opponent
doesn't have in this case black has a bishop on
b6 congratulations but white has the bishop on
b3 and the two knights those pieces can control
light squares so you want to dominate the light
squares and you see there that maneuver bring the
knight to f1 to put upon on g4 put a knight on g3
and if your opponent can't crush you on the dark
squares you're killing them i mean you're just
killing them so this is what dude is looking for
is ultra domination on the light squares where
you can get rid of two pieces but you're still
gonna be left with a problem when your opponent
smashes you on the light squares and here we
see just a simple play by duda although i will
say maurice it's the second time we've seen duda
play over there on the queen side when we've liked
his potential to king side there was that french
game uh as well so opening the b file it's not bad
for white but it does give black some hope some
prospects to open the position up and say hey my
king side is already weak at least now i'll get
some counter play on the other side of the board
yes and all the time by the way black has been
hoping to be able to take on d4 and capture
the pawn on e4 but he has to calculate it on
every single move and by the way we've been
talking all this time and dude has spent a lot
of time on the clock going down only 29 seconds
but there goes the knight we talked
about the light squared dominant piece
and that knight's going to end up on g3
there's nothing to do about it the bishop on v6
cannot come into the party so now white is
dominating black is desperate h5 please give me
a little bit of release so that i can go and guard
the f5 square he's ditched the pawn duda has won
a straight pawn this is going downhill fast it
certainly is because it's just an extra pawn clean
the light squares are still a problem oh
king on h6 queen g4 or rook h3 coming i
was trying to bring the queen h3 but the rook
is better the king stuck and he wins it's over
that was all about the light squares that was all
about the light squares in that position and the
clock times bobby spent so much time trying to
think about the position that he just ended up
losing easily and judah now has left the sicilian
as you mentioned yes oh yes excuse me yeah
sorry robert yes as you mentioned this the
sicilian was not working for him you guessed right
he said get out of there and he's out and he's
now playing petrol i'm gonna have to start calling
you danny i guess but he has gone to the petrov
which i believe is especially a dangerous choice
because the world's leading expert in the petrol
that would be one fabiano caruana so dude himself
is quite a promising petrol player he's an
expert in it but bobby is the boss in the petrov
it is true it is true indeed he is and is that the
fifth game in a row that white won it is yeah i
mean white is making black look completely silly
at the moment like just crushing and this move c4
hyper committal move blocking your own bishops
diagonal weakening the d4 square giving a target
on d6 square i mean you you see a move like this
under classical chess principles and you think
what are you doing like are you mad but the
key is that he's after squares he's after
specific squares he's after some control
he's saying that it's not going to be easy
for white to take advantage of anything especially
the move d5 happens and he's going to aim for his
own play with queen side storm so white needs
to prove something here i don't think it's easy
at all especially d5 threatens bishop takes on
a three eventually it's going to be a queen a5
and bishop a3 siding with a knight takes
c3 tactic amazing anti-principled move
and by the way 92 right now might
get hit in the face by knight c3
it's like bing bing bing wake up and smell the
coffee uh in a position like this you're gonna get
murdered with the attack coming straight at you so
very dynamic interesting idea giving up the weak
square on d4 so that you can get this dynamic
possibility for black and i think black has
real chances here to get b5 and a5 in uh or even
even queen a5 bishop a3 looks possible what's
up with that i guess you do have knight d2 now
because you put the bishop on d4 so if we just go
through this move by move we'll analyze a second
so we play b5 but queen a5 knight d2 bishop a3 i'm
not going to react by taking on a3 i'll take on e4
first which also frees up the d2 square and then
i can take on a3 next because i've stolen your
snd but b5 is the other thematic idea we were
mentioning and it's on the board and he's headed
places he's headed places with this move with his
whole plan it's not just the move itself it's the
whole plan white's attack looks ridiculously slow
like what is where's the target how does white
hit black how you don't g3 yeah that's he's not
going for an attack i guess he's trying to
play bishop g2 at some point and go after d5
and what's going on here maurice and what we're
trying to elaborate for people is that black has
the immediate positions like that kind of energy
that you have to use now or else white is going
to be better the potential the position seems to
favor white this knight can go to f1 to e3 if the
queens if you just threw them off the board all
of a sudden we'd like white's position but with
the idea of a5 b4 that's what is allowing black to
claim a good position indeed and the only weakness
is the d5 pawn but it's not under any siege as
yet knight f5 i he must not have liked going
after a5 maybe because of bishop c5 maybe that was
what was tickling his brain that stopped him from
doing it so now he's played knight f5 and now we
said a5 is coming a5 b4 in chess you need brakes
you need brakes and that's the break that's the
money break b4 so it's not hard to figure out the
kind of plan that black was after and that was it
getting that b4 move in he might even be able to
play right now but he has to calculate knight
to c6 does he want to give that move that's a
big move to give and he's decided nope i'm not
giving it yet i'm going to play this one he also
has to calculate any trickery like knight takes
on f7 nonsense you got to look at but thankfully
bishop takes is ready and nothing happens
there either so what is fabi going to do now
because he has no play he's just bereft of
any moves like devoid of possibilities here
b4 is coming his king is about to be at pride open
i'm sorry but this looks like eight six about to
happen for duda oh this looks great for him he's
showing a great understanding of hey my attack
is coming first let's not trade pieces because
my opponent's gasping for air the knight on e5
that looks good but it's not actually threatening
anything and b4 is what's all about fobby dipping
to 30 seconds and below due to still over men in
the clock another fantastic showing here for the
polish number one amazing and queen h who h a what
h.o.y like what are we doing that that's was there
a reason to give him a free tempe and now he's
dropped back but the a4 pawn looks man it looks
juicy if we could get at it but that knight
is guarding the the chicken house right now
how do you get at this this guy because you got
to break through on that side you don't you played
rook b8 by the way even if he didn't know exactly
how to do it root beat is a smart move right
they're one of the greatest moves you can have
in chess greatest ideas robert you know this kind
of trickery make a move that threatens nothing it
just builds your position yeah you can play b3 at
some point it does actually have a clear purpose
let's barrel down the b file right yeah it's
overall purpose but not necessarily a concrete
one it's just an improving move and it says
i'm not throwing anything concrete it's on you to
find a move and your opponent has to look now see
he took what whoa yeah he's getting all active
here but rook takes d4 comes to my mind and watch
out for this black king getting in trouble with
knight g4 at some point he got a little concrete
there and i was i was lauding the fact that he
was not being concrete and then he got concrete
and this this could give some chances knight g4
is not possible though knight c6 queen protects
c3 importantly and then tries to get the diagonal
man i want my knight over there on the darkness
the clock duda down to only eight seconds and
now he's in trouble on the clock this last move
the knight looks like it doesn't and he's taken c4
he wanted to take us before the bishop was pinned
there but are you for real three oh no oh wow this
is crazy talk and knight c4 and that's going to
trade everything off if he takes on c4 and takes
again and plays oh because bishop d5 rook d8
saves the day he's trading everything
off but white has enough material
yeah white certainly does i could play
bishop d5 then push or bring the king up and
white is perfectly fine yeah white should be
okay here black the preferred side because the
past pawns like going anywhere that's the thing
you have a bishop black can just block hate in
the dark squares very easily and unfortunately the
rook by itself is not going to be able to win the
pawns but time time is what's important is the
whole thing right now is they're both down can
they manage this position white is fine but can he
win is there a chance and this last move by just
got to be careful okay the position and giving
white the chance to play f3 king e4 when he's
gonna play it he's gonna put his king on f5 this
is winning this got oh why did he play kg6 this
looks winning but actually i don't see how to make
any progress that's the first or anything there's
no way to make progress there's nobody who can
break the dark squares this is going to be a draw
yeah it's like you need black to have to lose a
move somehow but there's always rook c8 rook c7 no
that was the key move he tried to trick him king
d6 so that he could play king c5 robert you saw
that sneaky action bobby tried to do he tried to
get the king over to d4 square now he's guarded c5
now here comes the king king's gonna come around
he's gonna challenge him to know exactly what to
do i think king d8 is going to solve the
problem though here he comes again and i
was another don't play at five don't blinking at
five is rookie five check so he goes back to d4
nah this is just drawing right now they're still
going one second increments is keeping fabi alive
but now he definitely cannot make progress this
is completely done completely done no way to make
any progress anyway the only person who can make
progress is black honestly if uh you know you can
attack the bishop and either win the c6 or g4 pawn
that could spell some trouble but fabio you know
what i agree with you if i were black i played
rookie one is there a danger to playing rookie one
no like zero danger to playing rookie one right
absolutely no now bishop f5 bishop d7 was the
easiest way to hold but this also does the trick
so okay the first draw that was the first draw
yeah we've seen a draw finally are we sure we're
watching super grandmasters play and look petrol
for fabi he says hey you thought you were knew
what you were doing my turn they avoided the
petrol this whole time and the pressure off has
that reputation sometimes of being just a solid
opening for black but it's been sharp over the
years fabian's infused some life into it for sure
but wow this has been an amazing match
it's so close i mean it's so close bobby
took the sprint took the lead duda sprinted
back took his lead bobby's still punching
and now it's a one point match this is what
you want to see close dynamic and by the way
very few blunders that's true we're playing
blitz and it's very few blunders is this
what we expect to see throughout the rest of
these matches what an amazing entertaining
set of games we're in for instead of matches we're
going to be in for as the speedchest championships
continue certainly the case and right now duda's
spending a ridiculous amount of time trying to
figure this position out i guess he's looking can
i push this pawn to d5 and free up the d4 square
for my knight is there something going on the e
file with my rook already attacking the knight and
uh having a good scope here but he's spending
so much time and i don't think you can afford
to do that in a three-minute game i completely
agree and then you end up playing the move knight
c3 after all that thought and what's curious is
bobby probably would have played instantly if 93
were on the board and now fabi's thinking i find
that fascinating sometimes players get into each
other's rhythms like one person does something
the other copies and here fabi with only 17
seconds having elapsed he needs to find the next
move quickly and he's played his knight to the b4
square what an interesting i'm not gonna say i'm
a fan of this move i think you and i both have
the same reaction like that looks interesting but
it's always a bad adjective because well he does
bring the knight to d3 and he can take on c1 but
that bishop wasn't really helping queen take c1
i'm i'm surprised by i'm surprised by a3 i thought
he would have played bishop e3 yeah and that way
knight d3 had no punch that's what i thought
but all right they went for something different
and again it's all about the clock fobby with
a 42nd lead and thereabouts two bishops as well
an isolated pawn on d4 white is going to fight
for activity the fight is the hardest maybe he
might even play d5 if given a chance so white
has maximum activity for the isolated pawn
while black has a solid structure e5 seems like
the only break robert yeah i agree and this knight
on d6 is the real hero because the f7 square is
what white wants a target with this bishop on b3
but the knight covers it and 95 looks to increase
the pressure please take me on e5 so i can take
with my pawn no longer an isolated pawn and now an
attacker but of course black will not be capturing
there and if you play d5 i'll push through to
c5 my bishop on f6 will be happier and i'll try
to use a queen side majority and knight is the
best blockader against and i was going to say
this after saying all that this calls for a judith
polgar g4 and judah did this when she was maybe
16 or 17 years old is the first time i saw this
idea g4 in the isilani position and man when i
saw it it came as a shock back in the day g4 now
is kind of like those yeah everybody plays g for
it but robert when you were gay high when you were
first coming up to me as a was it a nine-year-old
yeah the first time we met that's when those kind
of moves were considered crazy you can't play g4
in this kind of position but they started doing
all kinds of g4 in every position and here we see
it was something standard for duda but he spent so
much time doing it he's only got 45 seconds left
on the clock and just like our first interaction
you know when you play g4 you're signing those
autographs because that's a dazzling move often
but here where's the follow-up you know it's like
i got g foreign the bishop just sat back on g6 is
hanging out there you're speaking quickly bobby
responded with g5 yeah because he's a boss himself
that's the important point g4 was met by g5
like that's the kind of double double double
take in the bishop on g6 the pawn on g5
holding the position together very nicely
those dark squares not going anywhere no h4
threat no f4 threat that black has to worry
about the clock maurice i wasn't even looking
at that but look how much time fabi has and
he's in his petrov even though it's a sharp
ver what just taking bishop take him oh wait
you can't play bishop there's something wrong
i see h6 as a move oh what a calm move threatening
bishop g5 okay okay it's funny i was like
i know bishop g5 was in your head because
you saw you saw the uh by the way no it was
no it didn't work but i saw the eval bar go crazy
so i was like oh bishop g5 wins material but of
course the rooks and the was in the path the
vision base bottom line is duda has 6.4 seconds
left to play the rest of this game now it's time
for fabi to find a couple of nice little trickery
type moves and the game will be over there is
a blunder waiting and you just need to find the
right couple of moves now spend 15 seconds duda
is suffering at the board right now he's suffering
he he doesn't he just wants you to move
it look at this last move this is the kind
of move i'm talking about it does nothing i
mean it really does nothing there's no threat
right but suddenly duda has to be like
uh what wait what oh and there goes the
knight he's going to and and he's got to find
a move now bobby needs to find an incisive move
that scares his opponent bishop g5 not sure
that was it the queen now backing up to f2
the f7 pawn is under heavy pressure and h4 also is
a threat because the queen doesn't actually have
access to the diagonal agreed i don't know fabi's
last couple of moves did not help him he's turned
the game seems to have turned around queen
queen to d6 allowing h4 bishop back and h5
and boy there is serious pressure coming
down the f-file right now and it looks like
there may be a sacrifice bishop 87 what are you
thinking about yeah i don't know what he's taking
time for take on f7 this is what he was worried
about a sacrifice on this square is the knight but
this looks this what's going on could you straight
queens could have taken on f2 if you want it but
this okay still hanging in here okay this is this
is great for black that he got out of it with this
kind of no damage at all again the seconds two
seconds left for duda and fabi just needs to find
some simple simple moves this last one i'm not
a fan of the she's going in the opposite corner
he won rookie two no but rook f2 uh we're gonna
say but you trade rooks and probably are better
than the same king f6 the g5 coming yeah this is
good for black knight dominantly good for black
knight is better here but it's not over it's
not over it's bad but it's not completely over
and now the knight headed to the e5 square and
king g5 should be played right not to oh okay
and now you can't guard everybody and pawn's
gonna drop pawns are gonna drop like flies
now fabi's gonna win this one and the match
is gonna be tied incredible extraordinary
and it's the domination of a knight against a
bishop we hear the bishop pair how strong it is
pieces that can go on both sides of the board but
a knight can go from color to color and a bishop
has to stay on its own so here careful robert be
careful oh i'm not i'm not liking this technique
no i'm not liking this technique okay
just that doesn't matter he's got it
that's not gonna matter if he can trade off
the light square bishop it's a draw fabian's it
oh my god he has blown it this is a drawing
position no i don't know the king is pretty
far away so if black can shoulder that king
out can't you try to i guess you're not in time
this is a technical draw it's just a question of
whether he'll blunder it but this is a technical
draw uh as you cannot you can't block you got to
block properly you've got to block more than once
and right now he's trying to shoulder him so at
some point the problem is your king has to come
back to be able to bring the knight to the g4
square and here we go he's going to bring his
king back had to and now just bring your pieces
over take it and that's a draw bobby blew it
look at him shaking his head blew a winning
position that is a huge miss a huge miss for
fabi not winning that game you know what we've
learned maurice is the petrov is always a draw
indeed they had no draws until the two petrov
games and both of those games had at first it
looked good for black with fobby there then all of
a sudden due to turn the tables but he had no time
to figure everything out yeah that was terrible
for fabi that not not winning that game that
was really bad that was really bad and he was
disgusted at himself because that's a huge point
that he tossed away and they're down to what looks
like the last two games of the three-minute action
we're only unless there's a horrific blunder
early and we have not seen that in this match
i think we've seen it once i think there was
one bad game where fabi had that horrible white
sicilian remember that game yes and and there
was that other game where judo was black and
that's sicilian when he went b5 and just i mean
it can end that quickly but you're right you're
right good point so there were two sicilians where
they blunted but otherwise this has been a quality
match this has been a dog fight these two players
and just a small edge for duda at the moment bobby
really wanted to be at could have been it seven
and a half seven and a half after that last game
should have been now he's gonna have to do it all
over again and i have to give a shout out to our
top guesters from the last game because i
see an international master feeding master
two more ims and a gm all playing guess the move
trying to win either the cash prize or if you're
not a premium member win some premium membership
so great to see that and maurice i mean speaking
of great to see i feel like fabi from the white
side of this position the two bishops are stronger
than we've seen in the past and look at the light
squares that's going to tell the tale of this game
is this light square bishop and good control over
the vacated squares that black has created i hear
you robert i am trying to figure out how exactly
though white makes the pressure work on the light
squares i you need to help me out here because
i just don't see although that last move right
not a fan the threat is night it was knight
takes f4 and queen takes i'm just curious how
white oh if white gets the if y gets the d5 by
the way right i'm just trying that was the oh
it didn't even work that's funny it didn't even
work yet but that was the plan right right it
didn't quite quite work it if this bishop gets to
this bishop gets to d5 then we're talking right
queen e4 what a move what's a move interesting
interesting and strange to be honest because
you're after queen d7 you get nothing on the next
move you do get nothing you're gonna move your
queen now because now black is threatening bishop
g5 he didn't move isn't there a bishop g5 bishop
e3 siding somewhere uh yes i like that bishop
as much as i'd like your bishop on d5 i mean
i guess the bishop on d5 actually puts pressure
on well no bishop to d5 anymore but pawn's there
i don't get it if i put a
bishop if i put a bishop on e3
why didn't he put his bishop on
you're asking questions that i
honestly don't have the answer to because
bishop to e3 looked correct just imagine
this position same position with the bishop
on e3 saying no progress for you what the heck
why wouldn't you just put it there i don't
get it he's gonna make a draw anyway right
now no but bishop on e3 i'm playing the
position this i'm making a draw right
this is just a draw now this is nothing in the
petrol well we said they might be two more games
only but with this kind of position quick
draw they might be two more games after this
as they've drawn it's true unless this is a very
long game we will get two more and just remind
everybody of how young christoph duda even made
his way to the speeches championship he won the
invitational he beat sergey karjakin in fact it
was quite a lopsided affair and before karjakin
he beat jeffrey zhang and also the wonderful time
international master min lay so a very strong
performance on him he said i'm going to make it to
the speedus championship here he is right now he
is the white side of this position he is up eight
and a half seven f against fabiano and maurice
we're getting down towards the wire so in the home
stretch here we know duda is the favorite on paper
and the bullet does fabi have a chance or must
he strike right now in the final blitz games well
he's got to be even i think he doesn't want to
be down and then i have to win in the bullet that
doesn't sound right it doesn't sound logical
it sounds like he'll be crushed but he does
have his chances and he's been playing well no
i'm not sure about his bullets b we'll see that
by the way we talked about seeing our first draw
are we seeing our first d4 opening of communities
but they've played e4 in in every single game
we saw 16 games go by and one e4 was the move
of choice there was no c4 there was no knight f3
and there was no this d4 that we have now seen
for the first time as duda said it's time to get
away from that boring petrov i could be bored in
something else why be bored in the po fabi's super
duper petrov it's kind of interesting because
bobby played the french he won three games in the
french before he had to get out of it after losing
a couple and now he's headed to the petrov and he
hasn't lost any games has he no he did lose in the
petrol no he should have did he lose the game
or he no he should have lost no he should have
liquidated yeah right so so now we're talking uh
duda said enough probably he's good in the that's
enough let's get somewhere else and see what
happens but this one point lead is big for for
duda i think that's going to really matter and uh
this position is this is what we call a gm grind
where white says i have no losing chances it's
basically two results and black says i don't
believe my one single weakness on d5 is enough
this should be draw with correct play especially
in classical but we're not playing classical will
black be able to make all the precise moves or
does fabi understand these positions enough in his
fingertips robert that he's going to draw easily
you know maurice this is one of those openings
that i do not recommend for quicker time
controls because black has isolated pawn you know
you're tied down to the defense of that forever
and you're not actually targeting anything of
whites look at this queen on d4 it's a marvelous
piece keeping the rook on a8 stuck to the pawn
a7 putting pressure on the d5 square protecting
b2 for good measure so i just think it's very
difficult for father to play and you're right that
if this were a classical game fabi's so strong i
wouldn't be too worried about his chances i don't
know something about it just feels so easy for
white to play and not so easy for black to deal
with sure it is sure it is very easy for white to
play and now white offers an end game which black
will probably accept and he has done so these
are just the types that gm's at this level as
you mentioned there's no counter play for black
but gm's at this level feel like there's only one
weakness the right pieces get traded off i have no
worries maybe i'll move like f6 and put the bishop
back on e6 it's just just i mean of course this
knight is headed to d4 so you'll see the knight
probably repurpose itself e5 is not a real square
for this piece rook c8 is inviting more draws
as well so you have to be very careful there
uh it's just just a droid type position rook c7
on the board and look at this giving giving
the pawn on b7 because of mass liquidation
do you buy this there might be some back rank
tactics with knight c5 coming that's what i'm
worried about for white because uh if i could take
on first i'll kick your knight from e5 with an f6
in timely fashion and i'll take your bishop
on d3 and your rook will be overloaded
defending the bishop and the first rank
i know that may be hard to visualize
that's slick i'm gonna say that's real slick
uh like this right i get uh but is it true
it's slick but is it true i just want to know
because this is the you know the knight g6 you get
a check i go away you take i take it they can take
and you say my two pawns versus your two pieces
well well well very fancy very fancy just to
remind everybody the back rank is what we're
focused on so the rook can't take the night
but as we get back to the game rook c1 was
played 96 and maurice now i'm definitely going
to say you are right the pieces are coming off
white is still a smidgen better but that's all
that it is and i've seen uh this is not enough
no it's not i've seen players um you know just
win these games from the white side arena crush
is one player who is excels at these types of
positions i remember from the 2018 olympiad
against henrikh dramale she gave her the iceland
a pawn and then just squeezed her but this is not
it once the pieces come off mass simplification
this should be a hole you want a pair of rooks
you just want a pair of rooks now the only good
news uh for fabi the real good news other than the
draw i should say it's more than just a little bit
of news is that he's got a lot of time advantage
on the clock duda couldn't find anything in
a position where he would be slightly better
and fabio at the moment has a small time edge
he's going to just keep playing g5 you know you
start weakening make some weakening moves white is
gonna think about beating you here comes the king
first all right let's get the bishop out of there
i think that king is gonna start marching here he
goes it can go beyond b4 though folks this
is the problem because when you play king b4
b6 will be playable but be ready because
knight c6 will be did he just play knight b5
he did well that's the end of that we don't
have to talk about this game anymore we trade
knights off uh that's it that's all she wrote
king king d6 although how do you protect this
pawn because if i go bishop b3 and you go bishop
here i have e4 with a pin pawn that's a point
that's a point uh hmm maybe it's like bishop f5
to e6 or something like that so that way the king
protects it but still it's like it's crazy i mean
you can play bishop f7 in bishop right same idea
yeah okay oh h3 is his idea open the g4 he just
blundered oh he blows him g4 he just blundered
he just blended a position he should have stayed
solid he just blundered in seven seconds for duda
and fabi realizes that he just absolutely
blunder the position unbelievable
unbelievable he just blundered and now he
just has to give up this pawn he cannot trade
it to an end game and he's just down upon for
absolutely no reason and here comes f4 and e5
both coming quickly is it completely winning
it looks it looks like it's still well but once
you start pushing pause on the queen side we
might start thinking we might be winning again
but still it looks obvious to play for e5 robert
but it's not easy for white to break through after
this happens although i like the bishop on f5 that
was nice actually it just shows the limitation of
a bishop right if i put my king on a dark square
you can't kick my king off it and i wanted to
bring up something important that the a8 squared
matches the light square bishop because there are
times where you sacrifice your bishop and make
a draw with a rook pawn but not here because the
bishop and the corner match so e5 he's going to
have to go for it but then there's no progress
to be made at least that's what dude is thinking
because the king sits on e7 there are no points
of infiltration for the white king that's the key
that's the key to the defense you're going to be
able to trade off the bishop somehow once you play
e5 and you see making a lot of moves instantly
hopefully he's not pre-moving a blunder in one
of these moves as fabi has just got b7 and beef
d7 and b5 on his mind as his repetition and
no chance to win look at that he made it
from what i've seen duda seems very comfortable in
those critical moments the last seconds it seems
like he will have the edge here it's not going to
be about opening theory the great bullet meisters
like the icarus of the world they know it's about
playing good enough moves quickly and also when
the critical moments happen who blundered there's
no way to predict it clearly dude has got the edge
from his experience and this but will probably be
able to pull it off only time will tell certainly
will be the case and while we're talking about
monsters and bullet chests for those of you
subscribed to the chess channel here enjoy the
second match of the primetime smackdown and please
pray for me because i'm playing daniel nereditsky
who is a monster at bullet we'll be right back
i'll take i'll take the first defeat nothing like
a comeback i'm not i don't generally underestimate
my opposition that was uh that was a fluke yeah
i feel like there's nothing like a good comeback
story so i'm happy just to come back to be where
we are right now did i hear the word comeback
okay oh knight g5 but i've been here for years
is this a line i have no idea do you're asking
me if something's a real opening i this is the
one thing where i'm in the same boat as you i
never i'm always asked okay i'm gonna be honest
my position looks absolutely horrible i don't
think this is a line no it looks really bad um
can i get a redo a redo yeah how about in game i
i can i suggest game three as a redo oh this feels
really bad i'm gonna be honest i think i'm losing
like three pawns here castle that b3 pawn is like
the kebab i had yesterday that looks really good
yeah my position looks real horrible all right
let's take this guy can you just leave me alone
i feel like i'm about 20 seconds i've played a
terrible open you asked me the thing is when you
asked me if it was a real opening you asked me if
it was a real opening it just threw me off because
i knew it wasn't real and it felt like you were
being serious and that just made it more insulting
i see no i was because i you know we never
know these days are these young players uh
playing all sorts of first you said
young player you're talking to me
so what do you want we need seven man i think i'm
losing now i i don't really know how to play end
games oh and you won a pawn back oh my god yeah
i did i did so i'm blundering left and right i
i was like okay if i'm gonna lose on time
maybe he'll like do some silly pre-move
and i'll get a quick checkmate i
need a group i need a group here
it's looking really ominous especially given that
he's down on time but this is the magnus carlson
squeeze um wow and knowing you don't get many
winning positions against magnus carlson nobody
does nicaragua's playing in front of hundreds
of people imagine being in his shoes right now
wow unbelievable up by four games well i
can resign yeah carl knows it it started
with 16 players and it all came down
to one man magnus carlson who won
this is a pretty great passion i
know people love hikaru nakamura
hikaru is the favorite for a reason he's a beast
an absolute monster it has been hecaro's speeches
championship this 2018 in karnakamura the overall
1c takes it home in the species championship
honestly these guys have played each other
so much obviously this is a rematch of last
year's scc final what a finish by the way
i mean that's been the story of the match
kara nakamura has just kind of out swindled
out tricked and out calculated wesley in the
critical moment up dude that's a nice
move wesley's shaking his head picara
nakamura holding that position
and we return young christophe duda has a one
game lead but we want to remind everybody to
get involved with guess the move a game is
selected at random and the top scorers top
guessers in that game will receive cash prizes
if you are not a premium member you will receive
premium memberships here is a recent game played
and wow 106 guesses that's a ton but just remind
everybody what's happening next it will be the
bullet portion if the match ends up in a tie
we want to remind our viewers that there will be
four additional bullet games as a mini match and
if it's still tied after that we get to armageddon
white gets five minutes black gets three minutes
no increment but black it gets a win if the
game ends as a draw so draw odds for black so
decided by the chess.com blitz rating and
that should be jan christoph duda in the
case of a tie and maurice we're going to bring
up the smarter chess predictions one more time
got to get your thoughts here do you really
think that dude is about to take this bullet
seven to three i don't know i don't know smarter
chess has been right at least with the first match
that is the five minute portion we could say not
correct on the second portion gave a five five
but it was really four four was the score so we
could say oh smarter just didn't get it right that
time but so what smarter chess has been very
right in terms of the differential and so i'm
not going to go against that right now and i
think that the way duda has handled himself
fabi could be in trouble i agree with you there
duda has been great under the duress of time
trouble fabi has had some moments of his own
but it seems like duda handles the mouse speed
and the complications better when the seconds
are dwindling so with that being said we're
about to have liftoff here in the bullet and the
first couple games i think are of the incredibly
important for fabi he cannot go down three games
and then hope to go on a streak so hey we have a
petrov we do have a petrov probably must be happy
to see a petrov on the board his instinct o'grady
prepared this for the world championship against
magnus so you will see some of the lines that he
thinks are the most dangerous lines you can play
and are we frozen or something because queenie
two has caused black to stop and think for about
10 seconds in a bullet game i mean are you mad
yeah what's going on here come on dude you gotta
move i don't get it there must be something wrong
robert you spent all that time to finally play
b6 that's that's crazy and now probably should
just definitely move instantly since he saw no
danger there knight d4 jeep on is not hanging
as far as fabi's concerned you can have it bishop
takes on g2 yeah you want it take it again he's
giving away even the h pawn as well robert saying
you want any of those you can have them because
i'm sacking to get at your king he certainly
is but i like how dude has responded getting
his knight to c5 it's not even about taking
this bishop so much as activating the piece
and bishop b5 trying to get into the c6 square
it looks like but is he in time because bishop
c6 bishop takes d4 maurice that'll win a piece
for black yeah what is he doing well actually
he could take back with the c pawn and he's true
i mean with the deep the c pawn and b becoming a
d-bond and then hit the knight on c5 so it doesn't
quite win material doesn't look possible to play
bishop to c6 this is the kind of thing where you
got to be instinctive and just make moves and here
we see a trade trade bishop takes on c5 the pin at
the end white did not lose a pawn but the game did
fizzle out quite rapidly into what looks like a
bishop opposite color position and now queen g4
allowing rook to e4 not queen ca trading i'm a bit
surprised by that i liked your rookie four move
and here it comes but maurice would even take note
of this look at the ratings next to their names
duda is 32-23 fabi is 29-24 that is a 300 point
gap however most of that will be in no increment
right they're playing a lot of pure bullet and
winning on the clock dude is at least i don't
think fabi plays too much bullet chess right so
no problem here for fabi i mean this game is just
drawn mainly but it's bullet it's equal i should
say but it's bullet chest anything could happen
although i don't think anything's going to happen
here as the trades continue another trade and this
one looks like it will be another petrov draw
robber petrov not proving to be anything in this
match and let's talk match strategy for a second
if you're duda don't you play this out there
just over 27 minutes remaining in the match keep
this going why agree on a draw it still has some
life left in it and black can never lose indeed
and here this last move by white was interesting
uh but now it's dead now it's deader than dead
although there is a king trying to get to g3
but you have to you have to respect whites uh
white's f pawn if you live if you give up f6
only 10 seconds left and he's done it he's gone
for it and push take this one what did he do
he's losing dude he's wearing this he just
blundered yeah he did bobby has just blundered
a critical pawn is it completely lost it looks
bad but it may not be totally lost robert these
endings can be no notorious for being drawn but it
looks like he is lost it looks bad the only thing
he could have going for him i would say that this
is the wrong pawn but he can't win this h pawn if
that h1 were gone bishop takes g3 would just be a
draw but you're not winning h pawn so it's a long
wait a minute but he just gave up a second he
should be fine he just gave him a second pawn
this is lost yeah he resigned that's just lost
incredible and this is what we're worried about
with fabi that in critical moments he'll make
mistakes like that one when he should draw end
up losing a game that's a big point to donate it
certainly was and you know i was kind of implying
it when i was asking you should do to play on
he couldn't lose the game but foley showed that
he could and now it's a two-game spread and we
are getting d4 once more yes indeed and that was
critical fabi making a mistake there and it could
really just go downhill very quickly if fabi's not
careful it could just it could just get bad so he
needs to stabilize he needs to get some wins in
he just lost with the white pieces duda must be
feeling fantastic about the situation right now
he certainly is and the good news for fabi is that
duda his choosing double edged positions and look
at this h5 trying to go h4 and white is trying
to get this e pawn going and open up both the
e and the f files just blast the position open
for your bishops but fabi has to be happy that
the position is not just dry and he can't push for
more even though duda spent no time at all maurice
the guy is just in good shape in the bullet also
these guys have been here before right they've
seen positions like this one and they know what to
do and here we see h3 by fabi was attending that
queen really what a move keep getting the
g file does he have a way to blast through
king h1 and rook g1 robert no rook h rook h8
is coming so you do have to be mindful of that
i'm looking at queen g5 is there going to be a
sacrifice on the square perhaps there isn't maybe
we're too focused on g6 but it does look promising
of course the bishop d2 i'm happy to see if i'm
black for sure a quiet move and now avoiding the
trade of queens but man begging the guy to sack
on g6 just daring him i wow that is that looks
so scary but the night guards the knight i was
talking about this knight on c6 guards the b4
square so there's no bishop to b4 at any point
but now with the knight there's no threat no
bishop c6 threat but what does black do when
he played rook h5 black is looking much more
solid but in the clock situations about even a4
it seems like aimless moves on the queen side but
he's make sure he's not going to hang that pawn
later in the game and maurice i'm looking at rook
takes e3 at some point for fobby just to trade off
some pieces get in double-edged position probably
need to score some points and he's up on the clock
the threat is knight b3 robert knight beat nice
and that bishop has nowhere to go to maintain
so he had to go for it he played e4 but this looks
like it just blunders material and consistently so
rook f6 and more trades for fobby he is
winning this position there's no question
about it but can he pull it off with the time
being an issue a knight g5 when when nice get
to g5 you got three oh it's i think this check
i was like no three wins the queen but he's
getting a knight of three's threatened right
now knight of three is definitely threatened
and he had to back up and it's up to fabi now
knight check and now this this king is frozen
there could be mates anywhere but can he get
over there and he's decided just to play queen f4
trade off and go into what looks to be a superior
end game but i'm not sure he wants to trade off
rooks i mean straight up minor pieces and just
keep rooks on the board so this last move oh
nice there was a mate threat robber yep and that's
why uh now dude is trying to push this palm but
the king is in time to get to the dark squares
oops sorry that was my mistake not now it isn't
yeah i i made the move by mistake the king is
on block and pump oh watch out for no there's
nothing to watch out for so this is weird
i keep seeing the eval bar jump up and down
black obviously was much better but now
the king is cut off on d8 and that palm d6
can't be approached no this doesn't look winning
anymore just and he's played this move hoping to
chase the bishop away but this looks like it
should just be drawn he can get into e6 oh no
and white suddenly picks off the pawn on g6 and
he's going to push his h pawn and that f5 pawn
is dead as well absolutely atrocious collapse by
fabi with the second sticking down robert and he
can be mad at you because every time you say it
looks like it's going to be a draw he loses so
those are the words that fabiano does not want to
hear ever again no more draws the problem is he's
not cool under the clock ticking pressure when it
comes down to five or six seconds left that's when
duda is winning these games duda is super cool in
the critical moments knows exactly what to do to
manage things and fabi just seems to be collapsing
every time he certainly is he was winning that
position right he was up a pawn he was attacking
duda and then somehow he liquidated into this rook
and bishop ending and the rooks got traded and
he couldn't win and not just that he lost it's
one thing not to win the game it's another
thing losers yeah so let the guys king just
march into your house and take all your cookies
that was not cool that was terrible and now fabi
desperate to just get a draw but i'm not sure you
know we've been talking about as you said robert
i'm not sure he's going to be getting any freebies
wait that bishop oh it didn't get trapped wow that
was close it was really close and the worst part
about this position maurice is it's closed so fabi
can play now he can definitely play this pawn
on b4 is a clear target and the king can try
to come in but that's why i like judah's move g4
the king can't keep running as he needs to stay
attached to the f2 pawn not that it has anywhere
to go from d3 but there's a bishop isn't there a
bishop to a5 yes possibility and how do you i mean
you're now frozen yeah but if the king comes to
b2 you bring your knight back to c3 and you have
knight d1 at the end of these things so it's weird
and i know we've used that word a lot today but
it seems like white's king can't go and approach
the pawn assuming the knight to kick it and if
that's the case then black is holding steady
and there goes the king and now no
movement there how to do anything here
probably take and play you
know go for e5 here it comes
dude is just out playing him incredible incredible
and now now that he's captured this this is
problematic this is problematic he's backing up
knight c1 didn't just win the b-pawn whose b-pawn
was worse after all well now it looks like he's
trying to trade off and get his draw if he can
we've seen it oh try to trick him with
knight d3 if you take on b4 his knight d3
painful just trickery everywhere and he had
to move his king and knight there anyway
and he's just squeezing him with almost no
material on the board he's preventing him
from having any moves here comes king e4 why
not just bring that king in knight c1 check
and then you take on b3 and this king is
just walking in or winning the e3 pawn
oh this is it no check check king if two
and then when you take you can take on b4
uh i was trying to go king d3 at the end there
but you might be right maybe it's like barely just
holding on and here you know another variation
here asking white white's about to get in zugsvang
however a little bit of challenge for him as
the bishop is headed to g5 with the d4 threat
and this is problematic and it's there not only
is it problematic it's on the board it's over
duda is owning the position bishop takes isn't
d3 winning material yep he takes here first but
d3 still promising but maybe there's even his
bishop retreat and then d3 with tempo he takes
well he sees the yummies on the other side of the
board you can't stop those phones from dropping
completely devastating fabiano right now in
the bullet all predictions looking very good
and a 12 to 8 score three wins in
a row the way fabi started this
this match he won three in a row it is duda's
turn to show his superiority in the bullet
as he's won three in a row will it only be 7-3
robert because right now it's just a one-way train
running all over bobby's tracks yeah i don't think
that dude is going to look back from here and he
is winning all these games he's a great position
in this one as well and fabi's in that mindset now
i don't care if i lose because i have to win right
you a draw is getting close to the same as a loss
because they're only just under 18 minutes left as
the match clock ticks down and all right so taking
on c4 is possible here do it don't think i mean
just go for it you have to right you have to just
go and he's just worried about age 4-h he's not
this is not the time to hesitate or think you've
got to make moves and this he did he did pause and
now by playing b4 by pausing so long to play b4
he has now shut down his own attack and he has
to restart the whole thing and this is not good
it is a king's indian style with f5 and maybe f4
coming but yeah your kings on g8 the opponent's
kings on the queen side so whose attack is going
to be better i don't really see an attack against
this white king because of the pawn on b4 not
allowing about to open up that side of the board
but i don't see white's attack either mixed bag
here right but that's we wanted to get some attack
from for black that's what the whole position
was supposed to be about and white will look to
make those pawn breaks g4 eventually will come
on that side of the board black sometimes wants
to play the move e4 when the timing is right if
you could combine it with an opening on the other
side of the board as well robert wouldn't it be
sweet if you had already taken the pawn on c4
wouldn't that be nice to just have an open
file directed at white's king it certainly
would and unfortunately for fabi that's no longer
a possibility he loses bishop but the knight is a
reasonable defender but you're right maurice
i'm looking at g4 ideas how does black attack
here knight coming to c5 does make sense and then
perhaps there is an e4 you saw this a mile away
well i was trying to open up a line for the
bill we took them on that is some real i'm
honest right there boy oh my goodness he took
the pawn on before and said i don't believe you
have a strong enough attack i'm going for it i
would never have even thought twice once maybe
but twice we're taking this pawn on that square
now look at the punishment as black's pieces
are just making this incursion on the dark
squares incredible oh my god look at black's
pieces my goodness it gets better and better
but wait wait wait you give the so the queen's
up for a couple of rooks rookie seven coming this
king of g8 isn't so safe either what's happening
i'm not sure but this now queen b4 and the queen
showing its skill as a versatile attacker and this
is definitely winning now for white uh for black
excuse me no question about it but will he make
sure he doesn't blunder somehow in this position
and he doesn't have much time and we know what
happens we're probably wasting time trouble he's
gonna scoop off all these pawns now the bishop one
g7 on attack and go here quickie to check okay
takes this one said wait he's just taking all
of them dangerous position though he has not
figured out he's let the king go all the way
down the board and he missed the mate and look at
this the valuation nest is about level here which
means that white's probably going to win white
is definitely for choice now unbelievable what
has happened here what a turnaround bobby blew
that game if you don't win this game you win none
you if you can't win a game like this one you
you're not winning any of the games unbelievable
that he lost that game oh yeah we're gonna bring
the analysis board because he missed checkmate in
two moves and that's something that you can't miss
right when he started moving his queen away here
at this point queen b3 check king takes
c5 queens e3 is made and i know it's not
the first thing that may come to your
mind but you have to find the checkmate
you have to find the checkmate the first check
is easy the next one you look for that's you have
to find the checkmate by the way even in even in
that position queen b6 check picks off the knight
picks up the bishop on f6 so you have to keep
relentlessly attacking on every move that's what
you do in a position like this you don't start
going over the other side and messing around
no this this was critical this was critical and
now he's down five and this match is done yeah
down five with just under 14 minutes he
technically has a chance but if he couldn't win
that game it's very unlikely he's gonna start
winning five in a row but duda has done that
himself against alexander grishok and against
sergey karjakin in speeches championships past
but duda is the one with the lead so i not sure
where believers in fabi's chances yeah nobody
believes in it right now and look at this knight
on f4 all of a sudden he's down upon is black
but you just get this feeling like black is on
the the prowl on the attack coming initiative
momentum everything on this polish wonderkids
side well i guess he's not so young anymore but
still he is showing his incredible ability at this
time control and look at that queen sitting on h4
wondering what it's doing over there robert
is one square is going to g3 at least it's
safe for now the bishop on b3 covers the
weak pawns and is a nice attacking piece
so i could see this turning in fabi's favor if
he's able just to make his pieces a little bit
more harmonious but yeah this has been all duda
it's been a great display of bullet skill by him
and wesley so awaits the winner of this matchup
i'm not sure wesley's happy to have to face duda
who obviously is just on inform great form i hear
you i hear you but i would say at the same time
that as this position seems to be getting
problematic for duda as white's queen has
gotten out of danger and now he just needs
to play something to deal with the potential
uh pawn com coming down the board he's up a pawn
he's got the open lines this looks good for white
this this is the kind of game you say this has
got to be bobby's game he's got 27 seconds with a
second increment coming at him each time he should
not blow this one and now the question is how to
finish it off rook d6 looks like a natural move
robert and then get the ball going down the field
but what is he doing he's giving black chances
right h3 check is going to come i understand
i don't understand now now he's being hyper
defensive and that knight on f4 looks marvelous
i think now i'm also worried about getting
mated there's something weird i mean i i'm
gonna get three okay i'm just worried now for
fabi he's played this in such tepid fashion
i'm scared yeah this um he's giving up his entire
advantage me g3 now opening up the uh he might get
mated you're right i'm i'm saying i'm saying he's
on the edge of being mated he's got to be careful
wow a6 discovered none of them are good i guess
e3 also e3 looks crushing you can get out of this
96 check wait didn't that pick
up the rook it sure did look like
the phone was promoting the part without
wow tactics but now what about now is it oh
what's going on he can take that and he can take
that and in time pressure fabia has pulled it off
no yo seriously these games are definitely not
good for the heart medications i mean maybe good
for the may be good for the heart medications in
fact because that was insane that was insane are
you trying to say they're supporting big pharma
over here because yeah i'm in some pain watching
these games for sure but there were some good
tactics bobby staying in this match with that
victory and look at him right now he's above
a minute on the clock so he's in his element
in terms of the opening preparation and his
position looks just fine he it's just not right
about uh can't even speak it's not about right
now it's about how he progresses from here because
we've seen him get plenty of good positions some
winning positions and then in the scramble that's
when things go awry sometimes you play yourself
into form but then sometimes it's too late
yeah and we might be seeing this for fabi
that slowly he's getting there getting
there getting there but it may end up being too
late when we're done and this move 94 uh black
returns the favor by putting the knight on c4 both
of them with these tricky bishops black's bishop
is worse than white's c1 bishop so that's going to
be a problem but black can at least brag about the
pawn on a3 being a target that pawn on a3 will be
a long-term target so i can say i've got that guy
under control what do you have and look at this
trade on d7 for the bishop and now a trade on f6
white has a dream of putting a queen on 86 at
some point so black has to be very alert to this
possibility probably putting his own queen to that
score wait a second now wait a second isn't there
a bishop 86 bishop g7 idea robert you know yeah
straight out of brooklyn you know that weird why
g4 and e5 were the next two moves i know what's
happening this is what they tell you right the
best way to defend your king is breaking
open the center if you're getting attacking
the flight you can't do anything let's go but
you're right what the and here we go as now
this is a brawl with the knight on a6 that's the
one thing i'm not feeling for black right now as
white is intent on blowing him up knight g4 knight
e5 hitting the g4 rook allows rook takes on d4
so not a sensible move but h5 and look at the
attack okay knight 95 is asking again to be played
and look at four he dropped the tactic f7
check is coming queen did not belong over there
while duda finds these nice ideas robert when the
pressure's on and fabi misses little tricks like
that in time pressure dude is just an absolute
boss he loses one game you think well is he going
to be able to keep his composure and keep playing
the great level ability has been the answer is
clearly yes and now there are under eight minutes
it's a five game lead this match effectively is
over five games we'll do it no question about it
the question will now be the margin plus five at
the moment smarter chess said it was gonna be
a four game margin is plus five at the moment
so close indeed and all he needs is a few draws
those duda for this to be completely over over
not good for fobby fans at all and this game no
exception to that black is up a pawn white has
you know quality rook on d1 bishop one b6 great
but you're down upon as we're entering towards a
pure ending and i mean dude is just a monster a
lot of money at stake of course that dude is gonna
take the lion's share the two thousand dollars for
being the winner plus the win percentage uh it's
all going his way he should be a very happy what's
he 21 22 he's a youngster getting a good payday
indeed and look at this evil two connected passers
white desperate right here you you know when
you're losing badly robert we've all been there
and whatever you do it feels like fluff your
opponent just swatting your moves like flies
like get out of here that's nothing i'ma stop that
i'm gonna take this i'm gonna own you and now he's
taking yet another pawn probably made it a vein
attempt with g4 and it just as strong as fabi is
you feel weak you feel helpless as your opponent
just finds every move look at this trick knight
d7 instantly you couldn't take on b7 i mean
he's showing off right now rook d7 looking
for more traffic take his g5 i mean the guy is
just come on man on every move he's finding this
ridiculous skill and just winning with style
and ease and composure and flow up six right now
you know maurice we started off this match
fabi was up three nothing right we're like
dang like this is going potentially a lopsided
affair in fobby's favor and then something
started clicking for duda and it's just a totally
different match from the start of the five minute
you know what is four to one fabi ever since it's
been all young kristoff and he looks like he's
smiling right now laughing enjoying this bobby's
leaning back probably he's no longer interested
he's no longer interested he knows
the match is over he's down six
he got punished pummeled into submission and he's
leaning back he's he can't bring himself to come
up to the screen and really focus he's just making
moves now because he just wants it to be over
and well fortunately for him there's only five
minutes remaining but yeah it must be frustrating
for fabi because year after year he takes part
in the speeches championship and well it's you
know hard for him he lost to levon oroni and i
think it was like 20 to 5 or 21 to 5 something
ridiculous for a player of fabiano's caliber
but something about these blitz and eventually
the bullet portion they don't go his way he
needs to continue working on that you know
it's interesting because i think fabi's probably
relieved to be gone like just you know okay okay
he did not want to lose let's be let's be fair but
bobby's trying to become the world chess champion
there's no other ambition he has he's trying
to become the world chess champion the way he's
going to do that he's going to be to win candidate
match again matches or candice tournament again
and face the best player in the world and beat
him and this one minute is not his thing he's
not going to sit around and become a maestro at
bullet chest he's just not he's not going to spend
hours and hours and days and days and weeks and
weeks so that one day he can say hey guys i'm
good at bullet now that's just not him he's not
going to do that he'll leave the bullet specialist
he'll leave bullet chest to the bullet specialist
he'll try to do well when the time comes but he's
not going to spend all his time trying to do
this and he'll compete in these events he you
know now he's really in a lot of trouble again
in this position but you know frankly he's just
this is not what he's about yeah no i think
you summed it up very well that his focus is
very clear he wants to do well when he's invited
and plays in these events but he's not going to
prioritize these speeches events over the world
championship that he wants to play in once more
so i'm completely with you maurice's position
again not looking very good but the match already
is pretty much done rook g3 looks possible but
there's quincy one check to be careful about but
rook g3 was trying to distract the rook it said
he goes for the d-pawn trying to kick this knight
away made bishop d7 and winning the d4 pawn
but you're right i'm with you maurice um fabi
has a focus and that's the candidates tournament
which who knows when that will even take place at
this point yeah in the meantime people are getting
good money for playing in these kind of events and
unfortunately uh for for fabi he's not going to
get the top dollar unless he starts winning some
of these online events and he's watching other
players who are getting it done ahead of him as he
just he's not able to keep up as well he did have
a great showing in clutch chess fantastic showing
fantastic match against magnus want some money
there but if he's going to win the top top dollar
got to be able to win some of these online
events and it's just not yet not his priority
yeah and magnus himself he had that interview that
jonathan tisdale uh published on chess life online
i saw and magnus said that okay you know bobby
steals a chance at the candidates he's down one
point at the halfway mark oh we got mated in that
one yeah i honestly i've you know he's stopped
kind of looking at how bad it's been for him but
magnus said that his toughest challenge by far
is fabiano caruana so that speaks volumes most
people in the know in the chess world see the
ratings probably number two for a long
time and it's pretty distant between him
and magnus but also between him and number
three so that's the toughest competitor
for magnus in classical chess which is the highest
quality of of games so you're right probably just
you know he's not going to focus on the speeches
but he has been better in rapid but that will
not translate into bullet success agreed agreed i
think this is his worst time control without any
doubt about it rapid chess and as i mentioned
clutch chessy did well because rapid chess he's
been better without any question but when you
start going not just for blitz but you start
going to bullet that's just not his thing and he's
not he's not interested interested in training
for this excuse me and he's not interested in in
overall even if he did well okay i did well no of
course he wants to do well but it's not the proof
the proof in the pudding for him is classical
chess and becoming world champ yeah indeed and
all credit to young christoph duda who has been
an absolute monster today he started off on the
absolute terrible footage like he wasn't even
awake yet but then something inside of him really
woke up and he started roaring and fabiano has
been on the back foot ever since so dude on this
final game here unless it ends quickly we have 35
seconds counting down this should be the last game
and he's going to win this match and it's going to
look very one-sided but it's all been decided in
the bullet we see here it's seven to one currently
in bullet in dude's favor he entered up one point
now it's a seven point lead by the way if we just
do a little math the match as you mentioned three
zero to start yes yes since then it's been 16
to six is the score 16-6 that is a comeback and
more than a comeback a straight beat down once
he got his rhythm 16-6 to turn things around what
a roll what a run and he just just plumbing fobby
into submission and especially in the bullet
that was the difference maker the bullet was
indeed the difference make because there were only
a points up there was only a point separating them
after the five minute portion and the three minute
push that's huge credit to uh duda because he knew
he was the favorite in bullet and the fact that he
was able to come back from that early deficit and
just keep the match not just close but in a lead
for him right that speaks volumes about his talent
in this final game here i mean look at this king
on e4 it's like a checkmate that it feels like
okay it won't get mated but this is uh not
not going well for fabi and he's just trying
it doesn't matter it'd be nice to win the last
game though you know i mean one of those things
it's nice to win the nice game but sharks
like duda they try to win everything and
they don't want to give him anything whatsoever
as dude is trying to blitz through these next
moves and maybe one day hit this king but it
looks as though it's all about the time down
look at that oh but he had a trick back because
the work on c2 was under attack but there should
be some winning discoveries okay where's the main
thing that is looking bad the maid is coming where
is it though look at the 396. gang up on the
on the king and finally a mate to finish it off
and dude is smiling there happy as he's won the
match 17-9 a 17-6 run after going down 3-0 kudos
he definitely dominated the match and we can say
smarter chess kind of had it right but not as bad
as the final result actually was i think it was
8-1 in the blitz in the bullet it was indeed so
smart exactly where the predictions were trending
and it was worse than uh even predicted yeah so
you have to give our a nod to smartchest accurate
once again foiled my thoughts and i just i'll
never get over it but you know really just big
props to jkd who scores a monster victory sends
a message to the rest of the field and he'll have
wesley so up next wesley did defeat him soundly in
a prior speech championship but right now it's a
new young christopher duda some renewed confidence
but we'll hear it from the players in a few so
please enjoy the final prime time smackdown video
you know it's the last one clearly dania did some
work against me sorry for everyone who roots for
me i don't know why you do that but we're gonna
take our final break we'll bring the players in
for the call and we'll interview them to conclude
the speed chess championship opening round match
i came into this match thinking i
was going to lose and you know it is
all going according to that plan but that's
not the plan we want to see it happen today
it is precisely the plan that we want
to see all right all right all right
gonna take a breath gonna take a breath me too
uh preparing for you seem so chill right now i
always am can you put a photo of me on your wall
please like i see photos of other people there
and right i feel like that's my family robert
yeah we spent enough time together so yeah oh
you're saying you're family oh yeah you know well
maybe maybe after 10 games you'll be familiar
that's sadly probably the case so let's just
let's just leave me alone for a second daniel oh
this doesn't feel very good for me no
it doesn't i'm going gonna play this
positionally just get the knight back dude why
are you such a bully today i'm i'm feeling good
i've done nothing but be a friend to you that
feels factual we might have to reconsider our
a record then wait i think my
position is not quite as oh
look yeah do it come on come on man just leave
me let's see it actually no i don't like it
okay you think i missed that yeah i do no i didn't
i saw that all the way all right uh now what do i
do all right take credit back no this is exactly
these are the positions i live for robert sadly
that's true and i don't have much time so let's
just run my keyboard let's take this oh shoot
i forgot that funny thing is okay takes and
let's find the most clinical thing you're such a
rookie one okay at least you didn't lose your
queen you have that as solace you know you are
just getting a big head and i don't like it
i'm getting a massive head i always have i've
always had one i'd like to be dying that was just
a nice kid oh no i thought i had you for a second
my technique here is atrocious as usual but
i was so excited i hope you understand that
oh crap that is i didn't recognize the the
gravity of that threat for a second there
can you just leave me alone and not checkmate me
nope don you okay you're too good man you're too
good but you know what you needed something
positive in your life so that's why i agree
to play you okay robert hessel already
is a positive you have to understand
i play very little bullet right and so i'm just
here to make sure that you are a happy person
i see i see that explains that really explains
everything robert i mean i before this i i didn't
know what your intentions and motivations
were but now i do but on a serious note can
my photo go up on your wall that would make me
feel pretty absolutely i'd be i'd be honored
you'd be honored to have my phone on your
wall yes is he this is the type of traffic
that's just what i say to people yeah just
to make him feel good exactly you were just
bullying me after you just destroyed me on the
chest well it's like that um most interesting man
in the world in those dosakis commercials he once
had an awkward moment just to see how it feels
and we are joined by the players after
what was a very exhilarating match
young christophe duda congratulations and i
have to ask after you were down three nothing
how were you able to right the ship and turn
the match around and score a decisive victory
yeah i knew that the beginning of the
match might be very difficult for me
i didn't expect to zero out the three of course
but uh yeah usually i start with closing i think
it's my matches so yeah but i mean it's uh okay i
played quite badly in in that game obviously but
yeah afterwards i i was like kind of you
know okay getting into the match because
yeah at the beginning again often like not playing
very well yeah bobby this match was yours at the
beginning it looked very powerful for you you must
have been disappointed when it started turning
around can you can you pinpoint anywhere in the
match that you felt like you let this slip away
um well i had a feeling that the bullet would be
would be really tough for me i didn't expect it to
go as badly as it did but i had a feeling that i
would be a pretty serious underdog and bullet so
i was hoping to to make a mark in uh in the first
two segments and and yeah i was starting out well
but um uh yeah i guess that you know christoph was
still not fully adjusted at the start and then he
started to forget his form and uh i probably just
shouldn't have been playing the french so much
it worked out at the start but then i was getting
these strategies strategically awful positions and
uh and basically it was just it was a complete
disaster around that point um i also lost this
really really unnecessary game that uh when young
kristoff played took on f4 and i lost him like 10
moves with white and that was so yeah that was
that was a big disappointment around that moment
um then later it seemed like it kind of equalized
in in the three-minute portion it was pretty
pretty balanced um but yeah it was i i didn't
really have a chance uh at the end yeah and
fabio i was gonna make a joke if you were
playing the french just to get under my skin
knowing my feelings about the opening but um you
know you knew the bullet probably was going to
quite heavily favor young kristoff were you
working on bullet behind the scenes or was
that something that you just said i'm not
going to be able to get better in time for
this match to be able to you know equalize
the the score with him in the time control
no i i i wasn't playing any bullet i also
wasn't playing any blitz before i didn't really
um i don't know i i you know i've sort of been
on vacation here and i haven't really wanted to
play online chess too much before this
match uh and okay it seems like uh
i mean i i don't think that i'm going to
improve massively by playing a few bullet
games before the match you know um it's it's
sort of like i'm just panicking when i'm down
to seconds and this is not a thing that you
can you can really correct in a day or two
congratulations you play bullets so well what is
the key to your style to this ability do you live
when you were growing up playing bullet all the
time i did i played blood well i mean i thought
i was like extremely lucky to die in the bullet
because i was okay winning games either equal or
worse for me maybe even lost sometimes so yeah i
wasn't actually i mean i'm not very pleased with
uh the way i play bullet obviously the score is
too high like yeah i said i was like extremely
lucky all the time and um yeah i've been i've been
playing a lot actually before this match a lot of
bullets so yeah i guess i i was just not like on
the internet well young kristoff do you think that
playing in the invitational helped you because you
got to play very strong opponents like karjakin
jeffrey jean grishoek and minleigh so do you think
that helped you in preparation for this match
yeah obviously i mean you know it's never enough
i'm glad and well i think that you know to be
in good shape one can like have to play all the
time because otherwise you were just too slow and
yeah but as i said i mean that was extremely
lucky today and definitely was too high
i think you're knocking yourself we saw some
brilliant games being played and brilliant
instincts at the end of that one as well fabi i
made this point that bullet may not be your thing
and it's not going to be your thing you have big
aspirations become becoming the best player in the
world becoming world champion is that fair to say
that you you want to play and want to do well but
you're you're probably not going to train a lot
for bullet chess specifically as you have higher
aspirations i i enjoy blitz and rapid and uh and
i you know i want to do well um i mean of course
i want to do well in all events i play in um but
bullet is not something that i've ever had much
much interest in um it's it's not really
my thing um but yeah in blitz and rapid uh
i mean i i do enjoy playing quite a lot and and i
do want to have good results um uh yeah i i don't
think that i'm going to be a basketball player at
any time totally fair and well young kristoff will
end the interview with you you play wesley so next
and in the previous match against wesley so he
was able to beat you and seem to have a good uh
performance against you do you think that things
have changed in the last couple years do you feel
ready for the challenge of facing wesley next
well obviously whether it is a very difficult
opponent for everyone especially when
yeah usually you know um i either win i mean
nature game against wesley or i are just suffering
every game so it's like if i don't win 25
moves then it's you know going to be the
good guy yeah i mean obviously he's very strong
and he i think he was i mean reaching final all
the time yeah in every year so yeah but i mean
okay everyone is difficult in this tournament
so yeah and i'm happy to have a chance to the
revenge for sure well thank you both for joining
us after the match i know it was a long affair
um young christoph congratulations once again and
fabi's sorry didn't go your way but it's always a
pleasure to watch your games thank you guys thanks
and not only is john chris up due to the winner
of today's match we have several winners of
some cash prizes they guessed the move correctly
we have feeding master yavru court 40 that's a
repeat customer maurice winning the 75 cash
i believe twice in a row now that's nice man
you sit and hang out and watch some chats get
some moves and get 75 bucks in your pocket hey
that's that sounds good can you imagine if
you could watch other sports and do that
well i mean even better is winning a diamond
membership and look at that username beer chugger
multitasking at its finest right indeed
well congrats to everybody who hung in
there guessed those moves and took home
a little cash and some membership as well
for sure and you'll have an opportunity to
continue guessing the move tomorrow because
vladislav artemyev takes on anish giri in our
last first round matchup to decide the final
quarter finalist and we'll bring our smarter
chess predictions up that match takes place
tomorrow 9 a.m pacific look at this we have
artemia the 61 favorite 15 and a half 13 and
a half predicted final score and that is decided
no surprises here in the bullet segment what do
you think about that maurice well it seems fair
seems fair aneesh geary is not known for his
blitz prowess or hyper blitz hyper bullet prowess
obviously one of the best players in the world no
question about it but our temiev and these these
young guns super young guns and this is not
one of the the older guys i mean it's not like
he's getting the cane out yet but these these
young young guns they just seem like they
grow up on bullets and bullets and blitz and
anything that's quick the minds work a whole
different way so i think the slight edge toward
tamiya makes sense but don't count a niche out
of this match and i love our tenuous photo by
the way everybody else is happy and smiling he's
just looking like through you and he's ready to
grab your soul through your chest and then add
it to his collection he's he's the guy you hire
uh to to do to play the assassin in the in the
jason bourne movies you know like like this guy's
gonna walk over and say okay you know you know
what time it is right you say okay so it's over
now and he plays like it too he certainly does
maurice and i've had a great day here with you
it was a fun match of course the final score went
in one direction all the way for young chris of
duda but it was neck and neck before the bullet
portion so maurice any kind of final thoughts on
what was another excellent speeches championship
match indeed the first part of the match maybe
even the i would say the first two-thirds of the
match was so competitive was so interesting and it
started out with probably needing the first three
wins that it turns out to just keep it competitive
but in the end the part of the the competition
where we as commentators we really want to be on
the edges of our seats and biting our fingernails
what's going to happen who's going to win
it's so close maybe there'll be a tie
break we didn't get to see that because
of the spectacular play by duda at the
end to show that hey bullet is his thing
oh we'll see the matches are going to get more
and more interesting as the winners start to move
up in these brackets and it's gonna be amazing if
it's anything like the beginning of this match was
like future matches i think will be we're in for
a treat in the rest of the speeches championship
we certainly are and we heard it from jan
christoph due to himself he'll move on to
wesley so who's such a solid and spectacular
player that he's like well it's an honor to
play anybody i'm thrilled to move on we'll see
how it goes and with that i just want to thank
everybody behind the scenes doing all this work
our production team our graphic designers and
our moderators of course everybody who's tuned in
throughout the show who's watching and supporting
and maurice i want to thank you you always
make it so fun because you're energy it's so
authentic i know how much you love chess i'm
the same way and you know we go back but it's
fun every single time it's a new experience so
thank you so much barney always fun always fun
looking forward to the next time absolutely
see everybody enjoy the rest of your sunday
i'm not sure anybody's winning here
rook cietas the king is on age six what
come on now this is not real no way you're
surviving this position queen c7 a trade i
think they're just blitzing now they're not
sure what's happening at all what's this oh
my gosh here comes the king this is g4 is a
bad move g4 was definitely a bad move it did
not it was not correct but you know what right
around now it doesn't matter what correct is
you